that way
home
melodies
my weekend a magnificent
what's going on
oh [ __ ]
um
I am [ __ ] I just can't shake this
goddamn cough you know it's not covered
it's not Ebola it's not AIDS
it's all three
um
um yeah oh my God Happy Thanksgiving
Happy Thanksgiving
Happy Thanksgiving everybody
me
sorry to the Indians I hope you like the
casino
uh it's a weird holiday right you know
big meal wrapped in genocide
um how do we grow corn thank you here's
some blankets
um yes there's a dark history to this
country no pun intended uh
oh Jesus
sorry I've been mining
the last few weeks um
my cough's actually gotten better
believe it or not it's just I have to
keep talking that's the problem I
screamed my [ __ ] act this weekend see
this is basically when you don't know
how to write a joke you have to scream
the jokes
and you have to [ __ ]
you know
You Gotta Throw a lot of [ __ ] in there
the Peds of joke writing
um yeah that's basically it and I had an
amazing weekend
um I worked in uh Jacksonville Florida
which I didn't know was named after
Andrew Jackson
and they called it Jacksonville
is that nice
you know did anybody name something
after Lincoln called Lincolnville I
don't think they did
Jacksonville I like that
Birdville
that doesn't sound good
um
anyway
I had a great time there
um
I worked with Joe bartnick in Forrest
Shaw they [ __ ] murdered all weekend
and when we were uh in Jacksonville
we were driving down to Orlando the next
day
and uh thinking about Bob Saget a lot
still can't [ __ ] believe he's gone
um
but when we were going to leave getting
ready to leave the hotel
there was this uh Battleship from the
Korean conflict
never was called the war
and uh I gotta be honest with you the
size of that Battleship that looked like
a conflict wasn't a big one
sort of a mid-size
you know
like if the Mercury Monarch was turned
into a battleship that's like the size
of it
um
I think that guy from Amazon
I think his [ __ ] lifeboats are bigger
than this [ __ ] Battleship probably on
his yacht
um anyway so we were getting ready to go
and um
Force goes dude you gotta you got to see
this man he goes there's a couple of
[ __ ]
homeless alcoholics with a karaoke
machine and like
you gotta [ __ ] see this [ __ ] and they
were out in front of the thing I don't
think a homeless
I don't know what they were doing but
they were [ __ ] boozing and it was
nine in the morning
and
the white dude was singing Depeche Mode
it was like every [ __ ] reason you do
do the road or travel
and he was crushing it
and he was just going all I ever wanted
all I ever needed
then he was [ __ ] destroying
and then
his buddy the black dude was dancing and
he was drinking
you're both drinking and
I was just sitting there with Forrest
and he was just going like I've been
watching them for 15 minutes
and like just thinking about my life if
I'm actually truly enjoying it the way
these two guys are I mean they were
having
a [ __ ]
like they were having a blast
they were having so much fun I just had
an ear to ear grin I just I didn't even
participate
I actually it made my day to watch two
human beings having that level of fun
and you know whenever they do these
exposes on alcoholics that end up out on
the street they never show the ones like
this
you know in a nice warm climate climate
with a karaoke machine
it was kind of like it was mind-blowing
because it was you know these
skyscrapers around there and people
working in there in powerful positions
and they got the [ __ ]
you know their suits on and making all
of this [ __ ] money and doing all this
[ __ ]
and uh with all of this stress
these two characters right outside the
place
will [ __ ]
they weren't hammered they had a nice
glow going and they were singing Depeche
Mode
and I don't know it's just like
whatever they were doing wasn't wrong
because it made me and Forrest so happy
to watch him
um
anyway that was Jacksonville the show
was awesome
um
you know I've been a minute since I've
been to Jacksonville and then the next
day we went down to Orlando
and all sort of ran together you know
what's cool is I liked that you know we
landed in Jacksonville and then just
drove
you know the whole weekend so I went
from Jacksonville to Orlando down to
Sarasota Florida
which um
is always cool because uh
on my mother's side way back in the day
in the 40s and 50s
when my mom was a little girl they used
to go down there for the Summers
and my grandfather was afraid to fly
so they would drive
all the way down there I mean I don't
know what kind of highway system there
was
and they would you know hit spots on the
way down there to eat and [ __ ]
and I think I told this story before
there was one day
my mother went to a show and neither
Fort Myers or Sarasota
in July of 1955.
and at 3 30 in the afternoon she saw a
matinee show with a guy named Elvis
Presley
and like two months later
he did The Ed Sullivan Show and became
like the biggest thing ever but she saw
him when he was doing five shows a day
she saw him before he hit
and um
and like a half-filled theater like 3 30
in the [ __ ] afternoon
how [ __ ] cool is that that's that's
my mother's first concert
you know
mine is Doc and Judas priests on the
shield for Life tour
[Music]
um
you know
not as cool you know it's funny it was
like almost 30 years later 1986
I can't remember if it was Worcester
Centrum or the Providence Civic Center
but uh God I wish I kept those [ __ ]
ticket stubs they got to be somewhere
I know I never threw them out but
[ __ ] saw I saw everybody in those two
buildings
I saw Dice Clay
in the Worcester Centrum I saw AC DC in
the Boston Garden saw Cinderella in the
Boston Garden opening on that tour
well I see I saw [ __ ] Def Leppard and
I saw a [ __ ] Tesla
loudness I remember I think open for AC
DC on The Who Made Who tour
one [ __ ] time ago
um
um anyways I apologize for no uh podcast
on Monday I just trying to get over this
[ __ ] cough
I know what you're thinking Bill have
you seen a doctor of course I haven't
I'm German Irish we don't go to doctors
we start world wars
laughs
um now you wouldn't know this I haven't
had a cigar in like a month
it's funny how I stopped smoking cigars
and then all of a sudden
this [ __ ] happened
um
oh God
I think my son just woke up his case the
best
both of my kids you know it's great
because I'm home until like the second
week in December and all I'm doing is
hanging out with them
and uh
that [ __ ] garbage truck video
I got this whole thing now with my son
where's is this showing the garbage
truck shows up he waves hello or we go
bonjour
and then
then I always go to him I go wait wait
wait and I put my hand across his body
acting all dramatic like you're waiting
for the garbage truck to leave and then
when it leaves you go bye-bye
and uh he thinks it's the funniest thing
ever
and when it comes up I go wait wait wait
wait so now he does it to me he grabbed
his little hands he grabs two fistfuls
of my sweatshirt he goes wait wait
and I'm like oh
um added a whole new level
um to that video
um
having a great time and then uh
my daughter's like trying not to be like
the little artist you know
drawing and writing and all of that it's
amazing so
um and they also both of them beat the
[ __ ] out of my drums
you know hit drums like a kid like not
even afraid not afraid to make noise
just [ __ ] swinging the stick from
behind the head it's [ __ ] awesome
so
and then I got a bunch of [ __ ] done
around my house you know I got a new
garage door opener
I got the lights still like timed now I
had two huge holes three holes in the
ceiling got those patched up and plasted
for the [ __ ] rats came around
right
got the snake the [ __ ] snake the
[ __ ] uh sink snaked out hung up a
couple of pictures
[ __ ] ready to go I got six more dates
left
on this tour that started way back in
April very excited
got some fun cities coming up
um
what am I gonna be I know I got Boise
Idaho
I think I'm in Colorado Springs with
that horrible [ __ ] shooting happened
Jesus Christ
the [ __ ] is wrong with people
I love how somebody goes into a club
full of unarmed people and they're
wearing all this bulletproof [ __ ]
I mean just the ultimate cowardly
[ __ ] act
um
I swear to God
religion and Prejudice
unreal unrail the results of that
so I think I'll be there I'm gonna be in
uh Utah which I haven't been there in
for [ __ ] ever
to do a show anyway
um speaking of religion
I kind of like how Utah just does their
own [ __ ] thing
it's kind of got like their own little
everybody out there has got like 13
wives or some [ __ ] that's funny I don't
know if that's true I've been out there
I've been in a while but since I've been
going out there I don't think I ever met
anybody that had more than one wife
you know
how does that work out there Utah
when you come out to the comedy show
like do you have like a lottery
with your wives to see who gets to go
that's [ __ ] hilarious all right
I got two tickets to the comedy show all
right we all know that I'm going
so
since all you ladies like survivors so
much I figured we would have a contest
to see who could get immunity
and whoever gets voted out doesn't get
to go to the camera you have like oh
your own little [ __ ] reality TV show
um speaking
of uh reality not reality of TV shows
I've been watching that show uh second
season I didn't see the first season I
got to see the first season but I'm
watching the second season of uh
uh White Lotus with my wife having a
great time watching that
and I'm trying to guess what's going to
happen next you know what I do you know
I love I love that you gotta wait
you know
and you know what I don't love is that
there's people waiting for the whole
thing to come out so they can just binge
it
you know you just think it like the
level of writing and a beautiful way
it's shot and all the [ __ ] great
acting on it and everything that
somebody's just gonna bench it like
shotgunning it
you know cut a big hole in it and just
[ __ ] suck it all down
um
it's like people watch TV shows now like
they watch TV series The Way like fat
people eat
foreign
it's like gluttonous
I remember a long time ago
I had a really small part on this great
show called Breaking Bad I'm sure you've
heard of it
and there was a friend of mine I asked
him like do you watching the show the
show's amazing he's like he's like no
dude he goes I'm gonna wait till it's
done then I'm gonna binge it
and I just remember feeling like like
why would you do that
you know what I mean that's like if you
got like a [ __ ] I don't even know
what I'm trying to think of something
else like that
I don't know a bottle of wine
this Wine's 200 years old and you just
[ __ ]
delicious
now what can I drink
um
yeah look I'm just being a [ __ ]
curmudgeon every week I [ __ ] about
something if it's not to prevent defense
it's the way people watch television
shows I mean who am I right
I'm just a man slowly dying of whatever
this [ __ ] cough is
um who the [ __ ] am I
to tell you
how to watch a TV show
um
I like telling you what to do it makes
me feel young
you know I feel like young people act
like old people now you can't say this
you can't do that it's like that's what
all people do
the [ __ ] are you getting off telling me
what the [ __ ] I can't and can't do I got
more years than you
I get to act like I understand the
universe more than you do where do you
get off
being younger and better looking than I
am and telling me how I get that's my
fight's all I got left all I have left
you know when you get to a certain age
all you have left is telling younger
people that you know just to let you
know it used to be better
what an [ __ ] thing to do and I do it
every week
every week I bet you can find you know
we gotta have a new segment on this
podcast called it used to be better
the ramblings of a bald orange man
um
so I uh
I went out I flew the helicopter uh
um when the [ __ ] was it
yesterday
and um I went up with my instructor
because uh
you know I've been busy so I haven't
flown so I just go up and go through all
the emergency [ __ ] and uh we did an auto
rotation auto rotation simulated and
engine failure and I had the best
[ __ ] auto rotation I think I've
done in I don't know how long
we out in like the uh Santa Monica
Mountains also known as Malibu
and he just goes uh engine failure and
then you just immediately got to do it
and pick out a [ __ ] spot
and where I wanted to pick the spot was
going to be too close so I was doing
like s turns and I was [ __ ] staring
at the whole way down never [ __ ] had
I wasn't chasing it I locked in I kept
my speed right where I needed to be
and at the last second you know I was
going to left came back to the right and
then just straightened it out went right
into the [ __ ] you know entered the
flare
you know came to a full [ __ ] stop
didn't go up or anything like that
leveled It Off
uh pulled Powers [ __ ]
beautiful
made me feel it made me feel made me
feel like uh
like I knew a thing or two about a thing
or two so
anyway speaking of a thing or two about
a thing or two Jesus Christ did you see
the end of that Patriots game
against the j-e-t-s Jets Jets Jets
everybody in the world thought that was
going into [ __ ]
over time
was it a [ __ ] punt
I was in the uh I was in bartnick's
hotel room going hey let's watch the end
of the Patriots game it's going to go
into [ __ ] overtime
the guy runs it all the way back and
then you know they always call those
things back for some sort of a clip or
whatever there was a [ __ ] clip like
unlike the 10 yard line completely not
even necessary the second I saw it I
walked away from the TV I'm like ah you
[ __ ] idiot
I'm like Belichick's gonna cut that kid
before this game's even over
and for some reason they I don't know
they missed it
I don't know maybe the refs wanted to
get out of there but like they never
seemed to miss those things every time
doesn't seem like like
we'll say 65 percent of the time there's
a kickoff return for a touchdown or a
big gain well there's a flag back there
you know
we seem to call that
and that time there actually was [ __ ]
right there on the TV screen so
anyway
beat the Jets twice this year jets are a
good goddamn team so the Dolphins
everybody like all these [ __ ] people
picked the Buffalo Bills
you know
myself I picked him I didn't realize
that Nick Kroll was going to take over
for the Miami Dolphins and I already
knew that Nick Crowe was a genius
character actor comedic actor stand-up
comedian
I thought that his genius was just you
know within the confines
of the entertainment industry I had no
idea
that he was going to out coach my
Buffalo Bills
me and my Buffalo Bills
um
if there was a movie that they were
making about
the Rivalry between those two coaches
like they would cast the two of us
um
you know but for some reason Hollywood's
too afraid to make that movie that's
what I think
all right I'm gonna do some of the reads
here uh
hope you guys have a nice Thanksgiving
and uh hey here's one for you how about
you don't take the bait this
Thanksgiving and you watch your other
relatives argue with each other
wouldn't that be nice
if you didn't [ __ ] jump in
um the way I always do all right way I
used to anyways all right we got some
reads here baby all right look who it is
everyone it's indochino
you know the holidays should be
celebrated in style that's right you
should out dress your relatives and make
them jealous
make them want to [ __ ] dump some
gravy in your lap uh but why stop at
decking the halls when you could be
decked out from head to toe indochino
makes it easy to upgrade your look with
Made For You suits made for you suits
not made for them
all right It's Made For You suits shirts
outerwear
I don't know what the [ __ ] is outer we
made a jacket
for the underwear I never heard of
outerwear it's called a jacket
it's just a jacket remember that Tom
Cruise and losing it yeah it's just a
jacket and more
um and for a limited time shop
indochinos Black Friday event for their
biggest sale of the Year oh here you go
you know what's great about a Black
Friday sale online is you don't get
trampled
underrated taking advantage of a Black
Friday sale
in the safety of your own home indochino
gives you a fully made for you
experience at a great price and during
their Black Friday event Made For You
Suits start at just 329 and premium
shirts start at just 49 bucks
elevate your style without spending a
fortune
submit your measurements online or get
measured in store
then choose your favorite Fabric and cut
and fine tune the detail from lapels and
Linings to Monograms pockets and more
uh and Shop they're made for you shirts
casual wear and outerwear to elevate
your style from head to toe it's the
season of giving
so give yourself something made just for
you with indochino
sorry
um
where am I shop the Black Friday event
now through November 27th and
indochino.com and get 10 off all
purchases of 3.99 or more using promo
code Burr that's Indochine
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code Burr
oh look who it is everybody solo stove
huh are you a loner are you a renegade
are you a guy that likes to cook but no
one understands you
introducing solo stove no that's not
what this is this is a backyard stove
everybody
this is for everybody solo stove
um
where am I tootsol
um there's nothing quite like the
feeling of gathering around a warm fire
on a cool evening
and a smokeless fire pit from solar
stove makes your outdoor moments even
more memorable
yeah because when you have the ones
where you're breathing and all the smoke
with all that smoke inhalation you know
you lose Consciousness and then you've
you know you can't remember what you did
all right
then you wake up and your slacks are
down around your ankles uh because
I feel like I'm laughing
like that [ __ ] Hanna-Barbera
character on the Laff Olympics from 50
years ago if anybody remembers that uh
because instead of having to constantly
Dodge campfire fumes you can sit back to
relax and actually enjoy the fire
and during solo Stones Black Friday sale
you can get a great deal on a solo Stove
fire pit upgrade your backyard with the
solo Stove fire pit and create story
worthy moments without the Fireside
fumes
I made this amazing people get stories
out of that I just remember sitting
around a fire getting hammered don't
remember a lot of stories
sort of numbing the pain I remember that
stainless steel construction designed to
regulate airflow and burn more
efficiently so little smoke you wonder
how is there so much fire easy to light
with a few bits of starter your fire is
blazing in minutes you reminds me of one
time my body was on a date and he was
hiking up this hill at dusk and the
chick he was with
got freaked out because the sun and the
moon were out at the same time and she
evidently thought they were the same
thing
um this they're so confident you'll love
it they offer a lifetime warranty and a
30-day free return policy let the
gifting begin shop solo stoves Black
Friday event for huge site-wide savings
and get 10 off with the promo code Burr
b-u-r-r plus a lifetime warranty and
free free I can't do it 30 day returns
get an extra ten dollars off holiday
deals at
solostove.com promo code Burr
oh look who it is everybody
it's Master Class
um
master class uh do you have a plantation
master class uh brings you inside the
minds of the most qualified people in
all areas of life with Master Class you
can learn from the world's best Minds
anytime anywhere at your own pace you
can learn French pastry
fundamentals from Dominic Dominique
Ansel
improve your writing skills from David
Mammoth or Judy Bloom that's so
ridiculous that you can do that or learn
space exploration from Astronaut Chris
Hadfield
uh with over 150 classes from a range of
world-class instructors
uh wait with over 150 classes from a
range of world-class instructors that
thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think talk about how
good it feels to feed your curiosity and
learn a new skill absolutely
I'm into cooking I like drumming
and I like telling young people that
it's not as good as it used to be I
highly recommend you check out check it
out this holiday give one annual
membership and get one free you should
do this for yourself
it's all the misery and all the [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] world why can't you just
indulge in a hobby
is there anything better than a hobby
you know nothing but pure joy and fun no
expectations it's just it's just a good
time
you know then you get a little bit
better at it people like whoa look at
you and you feel good and all that love
you didn't get as a kid for a moment
for a moment you feel good enough go to
masterclass.com bird today that's
masterclass.com
terms apply
oh [ __ ] that was all Rosy to that last
thing terms apply what the [ __ ] does
that mean all right policy genius you
know we all hope we never need life
insurance but the reality is we're all
going to croak someday but mortgage
payments child care and other expenses
don't disappear when you're gone
they had to get passed on to your loved
ones because those [ __ ] Bankers are
so goddamn heartless
you know plus every time you don't you
deposit a hundred dollars they can
legally loan up 300 they actually
counterfeit 200.
so they're not going to pay the price
they're too big to fail you know it's
going to pay for it your kids so you
need life insurance policy genius was
built to modernize the life insurance
industry their technology makes it easy
to compare life insurance quotes from
top companies like AIG
yeah yeah and IG love in America since
2008 and Prudential in just a few clicks
to find your lowest price
with policy genius you can find life
insurance that starts at just 17 per
month for five hundred thousand dollars
of coverage and policy genius has
licensed agents who can help you find
options that offer coverage in as little
as a week and avoid unnecessary medical
exams oh look who it is
it's the lovely Nia oh
I'm reading advertising I know nothing
makes you more attractive attracted to
me than when I have a stuffed up nose a
cough and I'm reading copy from policy
genius especially since we know what a
great reader out loud or you are a
reader out louder
and policy genius has licensed agents
who can help you find options that offer
coverage in as little as a week and
avoid unnecessary medical exams
there was no reason for you to touch my
balls okay
it was completely unnecessary this is
life insurance all right it's your hands
off of me uh they're not incentivized to
recommend one insurer over the others
you can trust their guidance there are
no added fees and your personal info is
private no wonder they have thousands of
La uh five star reviews on Google and
trustpilot your loved ones deserve a
financial safety net you deserve a
smarter way to find and buy it I head to
policygenius.com or click the link in
the description to get your free life
insurance quote and see how much you
could save that's policygenius.com
all right Jesus Christ one more here
and
oh look who it is everybody Simply Safe
did you know that over the holidays
property crimes like burglaries and
packaged sex Spike nationally You're a
mean one Mr Grinch
you stole my new Atari
you're a [ __ ] green [ __ ] you treat
your dog like a [ __ ] Mr Grinch uh that's
why my friends at Simply Safe home
security are offering 50 off their
award-winning security system so that
more families can feel safe and secure
this holiday season does the Grinch
really have to whip the dog the whole
[ __ ] way up the hill
the dog's crushing it he just keeps
beating him uh order your Simply Safe
system for half off today you've got
spiders in your brain Mr
or your Simply Safe system for half off
today and enjoy Advanced security and
greater peace of mind this holiday
season an emergency in an emergency 24 7
Professional monitoring Agency use fast
protect TM technology exclusively from
SimpliSafe to capture critical evidence
and verify that the threat is real
so you can the phone calls coming from
inside your house uh so you can't so you
can get priority police response Simply
Safe as a whole home security with
Advanced sensors for every room window
and door
HD security cameras for inside and out
smarter ways to detect motion that alert
you only when a threat is real and even
Hazard sensors that detect fires floods
and other threats to your home 24 7
Professional monitoring service costs
under a dollar a day less than half the
price of adt's traditionals professional
installed system with the top rated
SimpliSafe app stay in complete control
of your system anytime anywhere arm or
disarm unlock for a guest access your
cameras or adjust the system or just
system settings don't miss your chance
for massive savings on my favorite
security system get 50 off any system at
simplysafe.com today there's this is
their biggest discount of the year
that's simplysafe.com
there's no safe
like Simply Safe all right well that's
the reads there let me uh I'm gonna do
some of these other things
these other things what are these the
the questions that people have
and I'll see along my voice last but I
really need to stop talking so I can
finally get past this
so I get past this horrible [ __ ] time
in my podcasting career all right
Australia are you thinking of coming to
Australia on
on tour I actually think about that a
lot
um it just hasn't worked out once I had
kids I mean I can't
it's a 14-hour flight to get there I'm
on the other [ __ ]
side of the world and hemisphere
uh I don't know I'll have to figure out
a way to bring everybody
but I would love to
I'd like to do what I did last time
start in Perth and work my way across go
all the way to New Zealand I had a great
time last time
um that was 2015. I can't [ __ ]
believe it
all right ship shortage
uh dear Billy gatesburg on Thursday
podcast you mentioned skepticism on the
computer's chip shortage the reality is
that this is true and it's caused by
three primary reasons the first is that
modern products utilize far more chips
than ever before think of all the cell
phones Advanced vehicles and even
connected appliances that is true they
figure out every way
for every device to be hooked up to the
[ __ ] internet or Bluetooth so they
can monitor what the [ __ ] you're doing
in your house
uh the second issue was that you know
when I was a kid the blender you
actually turned it with your hand that's
not true but you know
my grandmother did
um
the second issue was that the pandemic
crippled Supply chains and Chip
manufacturers were hit hard
uh
did that happen
seemed to be there was plenty of food
finally there's a huge bottleneck
when it comes to chip Manufacturing
has between 80 to 90 percent of the
world's Advanced chips are made by one
company
well that's [ __ ] stupid
Taiwan
semiconductor manufacturing known as
tsmc
oh yeah they publicly traded
I think that'd be a good thing to invest
in
and not think globally
uh the lat think about myself the last
point also is one of the major reasons
why the U.S and Western
world does not want China to take oh the
last point is also the major reason the
U.S and Western world
uh does not want China to take over
Taiwan well why don't we in the meantime
just come up with our own [ __ ]
you know
semiconductor manufacturing why don't we
do that instead of oh because you know
what that we wouldn't have an excuse to
go to war and keep our [ __ ] economy
going
uh there's slight good news I mean how
[ __ ] easy would that be to solve
huh
okay we'll make our own semiconductor
[ __ ] microchips why don't we do why
don't we just [ __ ] do that why don't
we become self-sufficient like we used
to be
there's slight good news the U.S passed
the chips act this year which was a
bipartisan piece of legislation that is
attempting to revitalize the U.S chip
manufacturing look at that it includes
280 billion in investment that's awesome
all right good for us we finally did it
I like to think that me screaming about
it after they already decided to do it
was a major part so you're welcome
America all the best to go [ __ ] yourself
in your new truck
I'm gonna get that truck in one more
truck and then that's gonna be my truck
collection I'm gonna get a Ford F-450
regular cab
um
and then that's it that was gonna be
those gonna be my that's gonna be my
Lamborghini my Ferrari an F250 and an
F450 I'm not hurting anybody right
uh Bruins highlights oh my God the
[ __ ] Bruins just are not losing
they're just kicking ass I've watched a
little bit of the games I've only seen a
handful of the games I've been so
[ __ ] busy but I've been paying
attention and uh
evidently we're exploiting the weak side
of the defense which I don't understand
how is there a what is the weak side of
Defense you got two defensemen
I understand the uh
the weak side of an offensive line would
be the you know if you overload one side
of the line
I get that by the defense so what is
that does that involve the forwards
pinching in and doing the can somebody
please explain to me what the weak side
of the defenses in hockey because Andy
Brickley was explaining it and I kept
rewinding it and I still just [ __ ]
did not understand it
all right but Bruins highlights you know
there's a really great website called
dtmts.com don't tell me the score that
shows spoiler-free highlights in about
10 minutes for every game from the night
before
well if you're seeing the [ __ ]
highlights
oh
I'm doing a podcast
um
uh don't tell me the score okay uh that
shows spoiler free highlights in about
10 minutes for every game from the night
before as a penguins fan who doesn't
live in Pittsburgh it's been great for
keeping up on how shitty my team is
doing
oh I should check that out
um see how great my team's doing they
also really she's recently started
basketball and baseball so you can keep
up with the Celtics and Red Sox as well
although I don't know [ __ ] about those
prima donna Sports uh six to eight weeks
with a calf strain
get a [ __ ] nerd
Bergeron played with a broken rig and a
separated shoulder well come on I mean
so did [ __ ] uh
Elon Musk there not Elon Musk uh what
the [ __ ] his name
oh why did I say that now I'm not gonna
remember his name
he's rushed for the most yards in NFL
history
he played for the Florida Gators
not edger and James
number 22 for the Dallas Cowboys part of
the three-headed monster with Troy
Aikman
and Michael Irvin
and Emmett Smith
I knew there was an e in it
um
oh but he just said
Celtics and he said baseball and
basketball
um anyway
thanks for all the great comedy hope
this helps go [ __ ] yourself you [ __ ]
well thank you Happy Thanksgiving to you
too
all right unelected leaders I think I
can read like yeah I got two more I'll
just read these
and then I gotta [ __ ] rest up here
[Applause]
unelected leaders still bill I wanted to
bring a praise to your podcast world
that you may find interesting a phrase
Oh I thought I was getting praise my
brother has a reasonable and measured
interest
conspiracy theory he doesn't think JFK
Jr is still alive or anything uh overall
I don't pay much attention at my dad and
I don't really follow stuff like he does
but every now and then we have to give
it up to him he's been talking about
unelected leaders for a few years now
and the phrase just passed through my
head because I don't care recently I've
seen these videos popping up from these
meetings where world leaders are
listening to bond like villains who are
get this openly using the phrase New
World Order
it's really bizarre I don't think you
could get away with something like that
20 years ago you absolutely could have
um Trump exposed that the [ __ ] media
has no teeth journalism is dead nobody
gives a [ __ ]
like when he ran in 2016 and that that
woman was trying to get him going you
said this about women you said that
about women he said no I said that about
Rosie O'Donnell he got a laugh and the
woman was like no you've said that about
other women he goes yeah you're probably
right
that was it
my whole time watching politics up
growing up I watched everybody all they
did was Dodge and deny Bill Clinton I
did not
have sexual relations with that woman
this stupid stern look on his face
[ __ ] her [ __ ] juice dripping off his
[ __ ] fist right
you denied and Trump was he said man I
[ __ ] whatever yeah I did it
okay you're probably right and
and I win the election so
um nothing would have happened
the same way they go from global warming
to changing to climate change and
they're always doing that they don't
give a [ __ ] the same way
the New York Times
wants to talk about how [ __ ] nuts it
is that you that that that Sports
gambling
is now become so [ __ ] normalized you
know and they think that that's crazy so
who do they go after do they go after
the NFL do they go after you know Major
League Baseball and all these no they go
after the owner of a Sports website
because at the end of the day they're
not going to [ __ ] with their money and
they make too much money off of those
things so they just go after an
individual that's how it's always been
and it always will be because at the end
of the day until we topple the [ __ ]
you know Bankers running our [ __ ]
lives it's always going to be this way
anyway if we're all taking orders from
weirdos and our vote officially doesn't
count anymore will you still be doing a
podcast so I can hear your reaction to
all of it if they let me yeah
it's basically how it works
um
old dad questioned
Sir William the red of freckleton
I like that
was insulting and Regal all at the same
time
um I want to quiz you about having kids
later in life I'm 48 years old never
married no kids
however I met an amazing woman and
marriage is almost certainly in the
cards she just turned 40 and has two
children from a previous marriage but
assures me she would love to have
another child do it
kind of freaked out about being an old
dad nah dude [ __ ] old dads are great
you chill you settled in your life you
know who the [ __ ] you are
you have all of this life experience
I mean that's how I look at it you know
if I if I had a kid in my 20s and 30s I
mean yeah I mean I don't know
I would have been younger but other than
that I was a [ __ ] lunatic
uh anyway if I'm not mistaking you
around my age when you had your first
child I was how hard was it to adjust
how tired did you get is there anything
else I should be asking worries and
concerns
um
how hard you don't even adjust you just
do it
first of all you just can't [ __ ]
believe you have a kid and it's [ __ ]
awesome
and you basically
if you love your kid and you're in your
life you basically just made a friend
for life
like that's how I look at my kids you
know I know I have the responsibility
raising but they also like my buddies
and we hang out and and we have fun and
we just try to make each other laugh
like I have a very
my family is very silly my wife as you
guys know is [ __ ] hilarious so we
have a lot of fun
and one of the great things is
you get to undo a lot of stuff that you
didn't like about your own childhood and
do stuff differently and you get to keep
the stuff that you liked
and um
no there's no worries there's no concern
did you get tired yeah
[Applause]
absolutely you get tired but you know
um
ask for help
that whole thing it takes a village like
you know you should have relatives and
in-laws and all that coming over to help
you out while you nap and all that
that's the way it's done that whole
[ __ ] nuclear family that people think
is the old school way of doing it where
you did it yourself that wasn't old
school that was the new way of doing it
we just grew up in it
and your parents had no help and your
your mom was a zombie
and your dad was working that stuff
that's not the way you do it like
um
you make sure that you get help
and uh if you don't have any relatives
around I would pay to have somebody help
you out and if you can't afford to do
that I would sell some [ __ ] or [ __ ]
cut out a hobby
for that you know
to get through that point until they
sleep through the night once they sleep
through the night
um that's like a game changer
um so yeah the first six months are a
little rough when it comes to that but
um if you're on the same page with your
wife you guys can kind of switch off
sleeping and that type of stuff but you
know having kids is the greatest thing I
ever did and we went out to breakfast
today
the whole family and the kids got French
toast
you know I got avocado toast what did my
wife get
she got a breakfast bagel
and we were just sitting there you know
having a great time and then looking at
my wife and just smiling like can you
believe this is our life this is awesome
so I wouldn't uh you know obviously
your life is going to change but it's
going to change
for the better I feel just my opinion
take it or leave it
um all right I guess that's it the old
dad question all right with that
speaking of old dad's old grandpa here
has to uh
take some cough syrup and shut his
[ __ ] goddamn yep so I can get past
this cough all right Happy Thanksgiving
to all you guys I hope you have a happy
safe one uh don't take the bait just
just don't get into an argument all
right and tonight Wednesday night when
I'm doing this this is the greatest
night to be in your early 20s and going
back to the bar and seeing all the
[ __ ] people you went to high school
with and just had this one this is one
of the great nights of drinking
[Music]
um
I guess you can hear this on Thursday
last night I mean that you know the
whole [ __ ] weekend reconnect with
people maybe someone you wanted to hook
up with I mean it's just [ __ ] awesome
um I always love the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving after you've
graduated high school during your
college Years while people still come
home before everybody splinters off into
whatever lives they're going to leave is
the best for Wednesdays of your [ __ ]
life all right that's it uh go [ __ ]
yourselves have a great weekend you
[ __ ] enjoy Thanksgiving and I'll talk
to you on Monday
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday uh November 24th
2009 14.
2014. how are you what's going on once
again I'm recording it nice and early
Monday morning uh
you know so I gotta keep my freaking
voice down I don't want to disturb the
construction
it's winding down everybody it's winding
down they painted the [ __ ] walls
you know well it goes a couple little
bit of electrical things a couple bing
bang booms which of course will take for
[ __ ] ever
um
I actually found out that I need a new
electrical panel
outside my house because uh the one that
I had was uh you know just a hunk of
[ __ ]
and uh so I go all right so take the one
off that I have and put a new one there
right in this [ __ ] governmental [ __ ]
right
he shows up
with this [ __ ] take measure
and he said there was no Safe Way for
his guys to put a ladder up because I
had this [ __ ] palm trees thing right
which now an even natural
okay
to the ecosystem out here some jerk off
liked him way back in the day
and stuck a [ __ ] coconut on his boat
or whatever the hell the seat is right
is that the seed of a palm tree is it a
coconut or is that the fruit it Bears
them within the coconut there's the seed
I don't know
um so anyways
so he goes nah the only place we can
stick it is right on the back of your
[ __ ] house where it's going to be the
ugliest ever and I'm like well no we're
not putting it there and he's like I
work for the government right what I say
gosh
right
as he goes to get out there and his
government issued Ford Escort station
wagon remember those [ __ ] things
um
so now I had to call the guy up and he's
got he's got to cut this [ __ ] tree
down and I know what you're thinking
well wait a minute I thought you were
[ __ ] uh Oh Billy treehugger you know
or William environment uh William Tell
there right whoever the [ __ ] guy the
guy who wrote about uh Lake
Winnipesaukee there
Walden Lake who was that [ __ ] boring
[ __ ] that wrote all the poems you know
everybody was freaking out all this [ __ ]
he was saying he was plagiarizing the
Native Americans they already [ __ ]
knew they already knew it was a great
lake all right they have [ __ ] uh
Twinkle Toes
with your stupid poems
the Native Americans had it right the
way they were living they lived off the
[ __ ] land they didn't take more than
they need that they needed right and
when you got sick some weird guy in your
[ __ ] tribe did a dance around you and
then you died and that was it okay and
it kept the herd thinned out
you know
he came out there with some the skull of
a [ __ ] snake or some [ __ ] on his head
putting line dancing to shame is what
this guy did and then you [ __ ] died
that's it it was [ __ ] over hey you
had a great 30 years
see ya
whatever they did that's not true
Geronimo he lived for a while didn't he
he used to get the senior citizen
discount when he took the stagecoach
after a while you know once the white
man took over
isn't that what happened
how the [ __ ] did I get on this subject
oh yeah taking down the [ __ ] tree so
now I got to take down this this I gotta
take down this [ __ ] so basically I'm
like all right so what if I take out the
tree
that really shouldn't even be here that
provides shade in an area that you know
never had shade because it's actually a
[ __ ] desert and you know by the way
uh what are we all doing out here
huh
we're all standing around trying to get
a [ __ ]
goddamn guest star on the reboot of
[ __ ] TJ hooker why are we out here
this [ __ ] place just freaks me out
absolutely freaks me out
um anyways
uh so now I got that so then whatever so
they got it then they'll put the panel
on and then up my electrical system will
be complete I can actually turn lights
on in my house and not worry that
somewhere in my house there's a little
flash of fire when I throw a switch
because that's what was going on
that was going on while I had a minor
gas leak
it's [ __ ] unreal I'm gonna tell you
right now whoever buys this house after
me is going to be they're not even going
to realize
the goddamn gold mine that they walked
into because all this [ __ ] that I'm
doing does not add value to my house
this is all [ __ ] that should have been
done right to begin with
you know
it's just when somebody you know
inspects your house they can't look into
the walls oh they're looking for is the
sweat marks on the walls and the cracks
and can you roll a marble across the
floor you know without even giving any
effort you know they're just looking at
[ __ ] like that
you know
he was kidding no they could walk on
your roof they go up there and they have
a sandwich they rub their balls for a
couple seconds oh it looks pretty good
it might and leaves
and that's it
what's he gonna get a bad recommendation
I don't remember who it was you think I
can find that guy's business card to
warn other people oh by the way this guy
came back with a little glint in his eye
and said it's a great house you guys
will be very happy congratulations you
got yourself a great house
um
anyways so whoever comes here next I
mean this is the thing they won't even
appreciate it
just like the rich kids
son you know
the son of a guy who [ __ ] pulled
himself up by his bootstraps
you know got into insider trading
you know [ __ ] bootlegs some booze
across the [ __ ]
God damn whatever the [ __ ] it is one of
those Great Lakes
oh it's late
[ __ ] Greg
right
then he goes out and buys some palatial
estate
he gets himself a trophy white he gets
on top of her
right boom nine months later Here Comes
This [ __ ] jerk off
he's born with one of those [ __ ] uh
what do you call the one little piece of
glass in your eye
not a false eye a monocle
he doesn't get a rattle he doesn't get a
baby [ __ ] bear they give him a
monocle that's how [ __ ] Rich this kid
is and he actually has a little [ __ ]
a pocket watch he's got a little pocket
in his diaper that's how much money this
[ __ ] kid is Born Into You think he
gives a [ __ ] he sits around and he's
bored right
grabs a handful of Molly and starts
rubbing up against the pseudo armor in
the [ __ ] house right that's what the
[ __ ] he does
you think he gives his [ __ ]
or even even [ __ ] knows
that he's got state of the Ark state of
the art [ __ ] electricity
and and copper piping going through that
[ __ ] 9 000 square foot Cabana no
he doesn't
you're kind of making yourself out to be
a martyr I am
anyways look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] seven
in the morning Marty getting [ __ ]
text messages
just never [ __ ] it never [ __ ] ends
it never ends so anyways
so that's the latest thing but this is
the thing we got the hardwood floors in
and a couple of you guys said you know
after you've been bitching about this
for so long you better sense you better
put up some pictures you know what I say
to you [ __ ] you
you're not seeing one goddamn picture in
my downstairs I am painting a picture
with the beautiful words of this
wonderful language
now I'm not showing you what the inside
of my house looks like
you want me to upload what the inside of
my [ __ ] house looks like
so then what you guys can say it looks
like [ __ ] and that I got ripped off and
then I'm a [ __ ] big-headed [ __ ] you
think I don't understand how you guys
operate at this point
I may have a Charlie Brown [ __ ] head
but if you think I'm gonna walk up and
try to kick that football again you're
out of your [ __ ] mind all right so
anyways this is the Monday Morning
podcast everybody if you're new to it
welcome
if you're from another country you stay
put
you state you stay right where you are
we don't need you anymore
all right
we're doing just fine with the
immigrants that we're abusing over here
right now
you sit the [ __ ] down
I don't even know what's going on
there's some sort of immigration thing
going on
in the news and everybody's [ __ ]
flapping their arms
right and the guys in the red ties are
going yeah I'm the [ __ ] out of here and
the guys in the blue ties are like you
know oh I think everybody should have a
right to be here right same old [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I love when they go like well the
immigrants you know they do the jobs
that Americans don't want to do
I love how they they always put it back
on like they always get it off the rich
guys
like immigrants do the jobs Americans
don't want to do that's that's such a
[ __ ] brilliant way
of saying that Americans don't want to
be grossly underpaid for back breaking
work that makes somebody else a zillion
[ __ ] dollars do you think those
immigrants want to do those jobs and I
love when they sit there and go look at
this they're happy
[ __ ] happy
bent over at the waist all day picking
jelly beans huh you want to [ __ ] do
that out in Candyland Fields I don't
think anybody wants to they're basically
saying we can't get away with Sweatshop
labor in this country anymore
because of unions
all right and then they but they spin it
around they got the Americans don't want
to do this job
you're telling me you couldn't find an
American to go out and go pick some
[ __ ] apples if you paid them right
huh who the [ __ ] wouldn't want to go out
and go pick some apples you get that bag
right you're walking around out in
[ __ ] air
nobody breathing down your neck you're
just up there picking apples like Johnny
Appleseed
I'd love to be a [ __ ] Apple picker if
you paid me
you know you want to give me 30 cents a
[ __ ] month to go pick apples yeah go
[ __ ] yourself you pick the [ __ ]
apples you'll see that they don't want
to work they don't have a work ethic
he's just Christian anyways
gotta go find some guy that used to
sleep on a rock under a [ __ ]
waterfall to do that goddamn job of
course you did
some guy walked here you know from
Zimbabwe
grab himself a piece of [ __ ] Oak
or whatever some light pink Pine or some
[ __ ] right doggy paddled his whole
[ __ ] way over here yeah you think
he's scared of picking some apples for
no money he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's
happy to be back on the land
but you got to go to that [ __ ] guy
that level
of struggle in life to find somebody to
go out to go you know
roll the cantaloupes in after the
[ __ ] Harvest Right
why because we don't want to do it or
because we won't [ __ ] work for a
dollar a month
you rich [ __ ]
oh I'm on a [ __ ] tear this morning
unbelievable
um
so anyways
so they're putting the tile in in the
bathroom we're getting down to it right
now we're getting down and I this is
what I this is what I've learned from
this [ __ ] job
this is what you do if you ever get any
work done in your house
have the whole [ __ ] thing designed
okay before
you know you wet you have them even
[ __ ] remove the first piece of
[ __ ] whatever you have the whole
thing designed you have everything that
you want
put in there and you already have that
[ __ ] thing priced out
then you order all this before they even
start you order all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that you want put back you're putting a
new kitchen
you order all of the [ __ ] that you want
put back in and you stick it in your
[ __ ] garage and then you [ __ ] take
out a stop watch and you go all right
guys go
and that's it then you stay on top of
them you never [ __ ] stop me you
actually in the estimate too you include
the [ __ ] that they're gonna put in
afterwards because these [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you go yeah what's the
estimate to uh you know to get a new
kitchen put in and they're like well
yeah 10 grand
you know what 10 grand is for them to
disassemble the [ __ ] you have
you know forget about all the [ __ ]
they're gonna find in the walls will you
know a little bit of a bro
uh some of this stuff here set up the
code this needs to be three quarters
all that [ __ ] shit's coming
and then on top of all of that
they're going to add the price for all
the appliances and all the counters all
the countertops and all that and you'd
be like wait a minute you this wasn't in
the estimate
and they're going to be like uh no no
you know what you feel like when you're
doing it's like The Blues Brothers when
they thought the beer was free
yeah like uh you didn't like uh charges
for the first ones
we thought they were like uh freak
no no
that's what your contractor does all
right it's there's no difference between
buying a car and having some [ __ ]
[ __ ] work on your house
you have no idea what the price is you
know like when you go down to buy a car
what you want to get from those [ __ ] is
the out the door price
out the door what does this costing me
don't [ __ ] act like you're knocking
oh I'll take a grand off and then charge
you 1500 bucks for the [ __ ] uh rust
proofing
you know
I don't know this is just the ramblings
of someone born without pigment okay why
would you listen to this [ __ ] uh all
right let's do a little bit of
advertising here and then we're going to
talk some [ __ ] here
like I haven't been already
let's get back into the podcast here
um all right so
last night I had Paul verzi on
speakerphone
and I had Jason lawhead in my living
room and we had a couple of Pops Paul
was driving home or whatever and uh we
had this epic [ __ ] argument
um it all started off with that guy in
the Giants making that unbelievable
catch
which immediately everybody started
saying was the greatest catch of all
time
greatest catch of all time
and of course Paul verzi
there's nothing Paul likes better than
saying that something is the greatest of
all time
and I'm just like Paul that's without a
doubt it's got to be top two or three
and I'm saying that out of respect for
the fact that I know I haven't seen
every great [ __ ] catch
okay
in NFL [ __ ] history
I know I haven't just out of respect but
I know goddamn well I'm trying to think
of a better one that I ever saw
no I don't think I can think of one
there's bigger catches catches that
happened in the Super Bowl but just as
far as degree of difficulty without a
doubt that's I mean I I
wouldn't think that you could maybe find
one or two better than that all right
but I do remember back in the day when I
used to watch uh Boston College and this
kid with the mesh half shirt was [ __ ]
running full speed jumped up in the air
and with one hand just [ __ ] reached
back and behind his head
and [ __ ] just snag this ball out like
a [ __ ] Eagle BC Eagle yeah there you
go snatched it out right and when I you
know was trying to find that catch on
the internet I couldn't find it
so this is what verse he says he goes
too he's like Chris Carter just said
it's the greatest catch of all time it's
like Paul that's his [ __ ] job
oh hey it's his [ __ ] job ESPN's job
is to tell you every [ __ ] night that
what you saw
or what you're about to see is the
greatest [ __ ] thing you're ever gonna
see because that's how they get their
[ __ ] money
that's how they can afford to go out
there and get the Corvette Z06 with the
[ __ ] uh look at me over here [ __ ]
racing package
that's the job I know Chris Carter is a
[ __ ] hall of fame wide receiver but I
mean come on the second you get on TV
you got to start flapping your arms
okay if they don't hear you your [ __ ]
sport coat bumping up against your mic
they're not going to give you your
paycheck
all right look what happened to Herm
Edwards Herm Edwards was a respectable
human being when he played football and
he coached football then he got on TV I
don't know what happened to the guy that
guy should have a red [ __ ] nose on
one of those horns every time he [ __ ]
says something I don't even know if he's
still on the show
I don't know if it was TV or he just
snapped her in that one loss where he
you know you play to win the games if he
just [ __ ] something in his head just
snapped
because he goes on ESPN and he talks
real low like this when he's setting up
his point and then when he goes to make
his point he starts [ __ ] screaming
right
he starts doing the Curly Shuffle right
well a wise guy
um so anyways
anyways so first he goes dude I just
Googled greatest catches ever
he goes it's a joke
to say that Lynn Swann catching the
Super Bowl it's almost insulting I love
that he just he
goes on the internet he doesn't even
Google greatest one-handed catch ever he
just Googles greatest catch ever and
then he sits down and watches some
dentists YouTube video this guy right
this [ __ ] guy he just puts this
together
and then that's it that's there you go
that's how I know some guy who works on
ESPN
said it's the greatest one ever and then
I watched some [ __ ] random guy's
YouTube video and there you go that's it
it's done
come on you guys this is I I would love
it to be the greatest [ __ ] catch of
all time all right but I got to tell you
he only did it last night and according
to my research
okay in a 12-hour period you cannot
watch every great [ __ ] catch of all
[ __ ] time professional and college
level and all of that [ __ ] but I would
tell you that that was definitely
I mean there's no way that you could
find two catches better than that I will
say that but I'm gonna stop short of
Paul verzi slash Tony Kornheiser which
I'll never forget in September of 2007
watching the New England Patriots
it's just the greatest team ever
and then they end up losing the Super
Bowl it's like you know
you know it's a real travesty is that
Tony Kornheiser doesn't wear a [ __ ]
toupee that's barely on his head
you know what I mean then you could
actually see how over the top half the
[ __ ] guys like that say because every
time they snap their head it would go
flying on the floor and it would remind
you to take it with a grain of salt that
for as much as Tony Kornheiser knows
what he's saying he's standing in the
middle of a three-ring circus going
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
foreign
children of all ages this is the
greatest badminton Championship yes
weird has ever [ __ ] show
um so we went from that
to then my [ __ ] phone is blowing up
here
oh conference call
conference call I don't do conference
calls
maybe they have a conference call no and
neither do you none of us want to be on
this [ __ ] phone call right now
can somebody just say the thing that
needs to be said so we can all hang up
can I tell you something one of the
greatest things about doing what I do
for a living is uh I don't have to have
you know there's no
um like meetings
I Don't Want To Tread on some [ __ ] that
I did oh by the way I forgot to mention
last week my uh
Comedians and Cars Getting Coffee aired
last week
and um
you know I was actually talking
to Mr Seinfeld by the way that was one
of the most surreal [ __ ] things I've
ever done
to be sitting there with him the king
um nobody did this business better well
I can't say Flip Wilson did it Johnny
Carson did it well you just go out you
hit him you hit him hard you get your
money and then you walk away
all right
and as they're tucking on your shirt
going hey hey you want to try to make a
comeback you want to try to do something
else so we can just cancel it
you know and put a little [ __ ] black
stain up against your name and they just
go no you know what I'm good
you you enjoy yourself Hollywood I'll
see you later Flip Wilson did that Flip
Wilson had his [ __ ] show he was smart
with his money he invested this [ __ ]
and when the show was done he's like I'm
out
see you later go [ __ ] yourself
if you need me I'll be at home rubbing
my balls watching the game for the rest
of my [ __ ] life
right
Johnny Carson look what he did he ended
up owning the show he had his own
[ __ ] clothing line
you know long before all those rappers
did okay they're all ripping off Johnny
Carson Johnny Carson collection
some of the greatest plaid three-piece
suits you ever saw in your [ __ ] life
on you you can laugh at them you can
laugh at him but you laugh at them all
right you're saying you don't like
Anchorman
if you don't like Anchorman you're not
an American
and according to some of the people I've
seen screaming on TV that means you need
to get the [ __ ] out of this country
how dumb is that
countries
you know
why can't we all just be happy we're not
in the water
right can everybody just [ __ ] relax
okay I got shoes you got sandals how are
you how's it going great you know I
don't know what that thing is on your
head but you know you seem to enjoy it
you want to come over and have some
dinner
why can't why can't you just [ __ ] do
that why does it always have to be
screaming and [ __ ] yelling
this goddamn Isis horseshit I swear to
[ __ ] Christ I would love to see them
try to [ __ ] defeat Florida
you know
sitting there acting like they're a
goddamn problem holy [ __ ] there's
[ __ ] 30 000 people on the other side
of the planet that don't like us well
thank God we're on this side of the
planet
why don't we just stay over here and
figure out how to make our cars run on
Legos and then what are they going to be
mad at huh that they got nobody to shoot
at [ __ ] them
okay
you know what it is about America we're
like back in the day
like one of those big [ __ ] a r guys
that could actually take a band out of
it pluck them out of obscurity
and give them a hit record that's what
America does with their foreign policy
no one would ever have heard of Isis if
it wasn't for us
if our a and our guys didn't go over
there and pluck them out of [ __ ]
obscurity they'd just be over there you
know no one would even know they'd be
like a garage band
you know blowing up [ __ ] over there and
no one would even [ __ ] hear about
them
all right why don't we walk away
tear up their contract and just [ __ ]
come on why don't we just come home
can we just do everybody kill come on up
let's just come up enough already you're
not gonna solve anything over there
all right but we want to stuff in the
ground I mean sorry we're trying to
we're trying to give them freedom
yeah
I'm trying to get Freedom oh come on
grow up okay but
just come up okay we have beaches over
here what are you doing over there we
got oil here
um anyways
that was my version of what we should do
with our foreign policy having not read
a goddamn thing about it
as far as I know Isis was some sexy
broad in the 70s
you know who was a rival to uh Wonder
Woman
you know because everybody knows good
looking [ __ ] don't get along
and the only way the only way two
good-looking women get along is it's so
they can hate on other good-looking
women and just sit there you know with
their faces all [ __ ] scrunched up
hey why does your face age but the rest
of your body doesn't or what is your
face age faster
you know like you ever see like an old
stripper the [ __ ] bodies are gorgeous
and then their face she's like oh man
look at that body that body looks 26.
you look at their face ah she's 42.
or me for instance you know what I mean
like if you guys saw me completely
[ __ ] naked you'd be like wow man
I bet that guy's like 31 and then you
see my face he's like holy [ __ ] let's
pick out a plot
um sorry you know what I'm not sorry you
deserve that you deserve to picture me
naked um
so anyway so we ended up having this
[ __ ] uh ridiculous [ __ ] argument
where uh
Paul verzi
of course was saying Babe Ruth was the
greatest baseball player of all time
and then he said all the usual [ __ ] he
basically repeated [ __ ] that he heard on
TV
they he played the dead ball era right
and uh lawhead was also trying to tell
me you know yeah he and I was just
saying listen I'm not saying he's not
one of the great players of all time but
he's not the greatest of all [ __ ]
time for the simple fact he didn't play
against the greatest all right he played
in a segregated league with the Pedro
Martinez the Mariano Rivera's okay the
Josh Gibson's they weren't allowed in
the [ __ ] League
he didn't have to compete against Reggie
Jackson he didn't have to compete
against these guys they weren't allowed
in the league he was playing in
basically a softball league
okay with the top third what I would say
would make
you know
would make the Major League Baseball
nowadays okay but I get you got to think
like two-thirds of them wouldn't even
[ __ ] been there then they try to do
that [ __ ] well Bill there was only 10
teams there's 30 teams now yeah and
there was also only [ __ ] two billion
people on the planet now there's seven
billion
all right so I'll I'll knock off like
I'll give him an extra 10 on his [ __ ]
numbers then
like give me a [ __ ] break all you got
to do
dude he played baseball when people died
at tuberculosis
he played baseball like there was a hit
song
and that song was written in the 1890s
and everybody thought it was too [ __ ]
crazy what is this devil music
God damn it see what happens when you
let him off the plantation they get a
piano
they couldn't even handle it
yeah
he played baseball that was a hit
foreign
people will just hear it
and then sit around wondering when they
were ever going to hear it again because
they had no device to play it on yeah
right
that guy came to town and everybody
stood around him and he played a [ __ ]
piano
you see how they worked out back then
head shoulders knees and toes knees and
toes head shoulders knees and toes knees
and toes and only white guys no black
supporter Ricans head shoulders knees
and toes knees and toes
those big dumb [ __ ] gloves
that look like little people hands
give me a [ __ ] break
not to mention Babe Ruth I mean they
built a stadium towards his strength
that right field fence
okay you can you can make a cop show
with two toddlers And they could do the
classic scene where the [ __ ]
cop chases to perp down the alley and he
gets to the chain link fence and [ __ ]
jumps over it you could you could film
that with two toddlers with the right
field fence in Yankee Stadium the house
that Ruth built all right
you backed up to catch a fly ball it hit
you like mid thigh and you fell into
some guy's lap
right
so anyways give me a [ __ ] break
all right from 1930 on I'll give it to
you
all right but if you played in the teens
he played in the Arts he played in the
1800s and even into the 20s go [ __ ]
yourself
all right and I feel like every
look every like
um
major sport has their Three Stooges
error where one team won a bunch of
[ __ ] championships all right I love
the Boston Celtics but give me a break
you look at them in the 1960s I mean it
looks like it looks like a game being
played at the Y
you know some Christian rec league
all right the [ __ ] Canadians want a
bunch of Stanley Cups when you know you
had first dibs on any guy within a 300
mile [ __ ] radius in a 16 [ __ ]
League
they at first dibs on anybody in French
speaking Quebec
and we we had you know we had first
picked like the best guy from Vermont
gee did you go on a run it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
okay and then the Green Bay Packers who
are actually the [ __ ] Yankees of
football you know
they you know they were winning titles
when the Canton bulldogs were still in
the [ __ ] League all right okay give
me come on
right
football was like a I think they played
with a pumpkin back then I mean give me
a [ __ ] break all those chin Little
Star the history the blah blah the only
ones that I well that I will I will
recognize their championships without a
grain of salt I would say uh any of the
New York Yankees from like the 1930s on
for the simple fact they went Babe Ruth
Lou Gehrig Joe DiMaggio Mickey Mantle
that's just nobody's nobody's ever going
to do that again you're not going to get
the Jordan of your error four times in a
[ __ ] row
all right you're just not gonna do it so
without a doubt I respect all of that
type of [ __ ] but you know at the
inceptions of these [ __ ] leaks
when Crazy Legs Johnson runs around
googly eyes [ __ ] Ulysses and give me
a [ __ ] break okay
he played in the dead ball era you don't
understand this guy had more doubles
who was on the mount
my great-grandfather
oh song they played when he came in
he said her Enter Sandman
they weren't facing cut fastballs back
then I'm sure there was guys throwing 90
100 miles a [ __ ] hour but just the
amount of bums that were in that [ __ ]
League back then I I don't even want to
hear it
there's a there's a guy in the Hall of
Fame
who for good luck
in baseball he kept a section of rope
that was used in an actual lynching
okay this is how long ago these [ __ ]
people played and you're gonna sit there
and act like in the Inception of these
[ __ ] leagues
you know look and obviously in every era
there was a Jordan
all right but just like the techniques
and everything some of the records that
were set back then they'd have a [ __ ]
heavyweight fight it would go on for
like a day
they'd have like a [ __ ] you know a
90-round fight
okay now listen you're getting punched
in the [ __ ] head
but what kind of technique are you using
dude bare knuckle [ __ ] people bubble
ah go [ __ ] I want to hear it I don't
want to hear it all right
the competition now is so much more
insane
that I I just think it would immediately
but I guess they would compete at the
same level but like just the fact that
it's now everybody gets to compete and
not to mention like I mean you could get
[ __ ] fathers out there I try and they
trying to teach that kid how to throw a
curveball
to get you know get the family out of
the trailer park when the kid's like six
years old
stunting the growth of one of his
[ __ ] arms
you know because they live in a [ __ ]
trailer and somebody's got a growth on
their face that they want to have again
they want to removed
then there's kids going out there you
know
back in the day you went out you played
catch with your little kid now you go
out there and you from day one you try
to teach them how to switch it
it's insane
all right so whatever I'm just saying
so whatever if you guys think Babe Ruth
is the greatest baseball player
it's so hard to say because all you can
go by is this guy's [ __ ] stats
who who played back you know
it was probably a guy better than
[ __ ] Babe Ruth but he got polio you
know what I mean I just uh I don't
all right I'm done I'm done [ __ ]
muttering here
all right let's move on here uh oh hey
did you see the Bills and Jets game was
snowed out I love when they have those
big uh snowstorms right and then
everybody goes global warming huh
um
I got a buddy of mine for a shot who is
actually on uh Conan O'Brien last week
he didn't let me know
you know because like most funny people
he's [ __ ] humble
okay and didn't even [ __ ] tell me but
uh he actually told me that that is a a
symptom of global warming now I'm gonna
pause here for everybody
you know
who doesn't think that seven billion
people
pouring nuclear waste into rivers has
any sort of an effect on the planet
you know but a bunch of deer do
they gonna eat all the [ __ ] trees we
gotta get them out of here man
well what about us
what do you mean we're fine
dares have an effect
deers have an effect on on the
environment
you know them things that don't drive
cars or pollute Lakes yeah but us seven
billion people
who actually us here who actually put a
hole in the [ __ ] ozone layer spraying
Pam into Skillets so our omelettes don't
stick to them
do we do not have any sort of effect on
the planet whatsoever
um
this I mean I don't know [ __ ] about this
but people are actually saying that that
is uh these giant snowstorms are
actually a direct effect of the warming
of the globe
now whether we do it or not here we go
this is what this person says the storms
that buried Buffalo New York area and
more than seven feet 2.1 meters if
you're from another country
of snow this week shattered records and
shocked the residents even even in a
region accustomed
uh to dealing with heavy snow the storms
are starting to provide new fodder for
climate change Skeptics who seem to
embrace every monster blizzard as
evidence that global warming doesn't
exist and yet the science behind these
catastrophic storms suggest that they do
not occur despite global warming but in
fact because of it
and he sends a link to the U.S India
Summit
uh
bring historic climate action question
mark I know this person wants it to be
true so I understand that I'm only
reading one side of the argument here
but this is this is actually interesting
to me part of what gave us the record
lake effect snowfall in Buffalo was warm
late fall Lake surface temperatures that
combined with something highly unusual a
five Sigma event oh [ __ ] well that
clears it up the hell does that mean
that is a very likely event on the
on the order of one in a million or
remarkable persistent
what's with all the big words dude
anomalous configuration of the jet
stream
which brought frigid frigid Arctic air
down into the United States so early in
the season
um the cold winds traveling over the
warm moisture-laden lake created a
perfect storm of conditions for records
uh for record lake effect snow
I think basically what they're saying is
warm air can hold more moisture
because the air molecules are more uh
spread out and they're larger
right and then that
for what I don't know that they don't
explain why the [ __ ] jet stream got
pushed down
bringing the so whatever so frigid air
hit this unbelievably warm air
all right and then what does that do
ladies and gentlemen we all know
that cold air is high pressure air and
high pressure wants to go to low
pressure
and what does it do
it [ __ ] goes slams into it and sends
all that warm moist air right up into
the [ __ ] sky
right then it hits the dew point what's
the dew point boys and girls the dew
point is the point at which when water
when moisture in the air becomes visible
also known as the cloud and if it's on
the ground it's more known as fog yeah
so then what happens is as that air
moves up
it starts to cool so the air molecules
start to shrink and then you reach the
saturation point and then the [ __ ]
water drops and then with that Arctic
Arrow underneath it it [ __ ] snows
like a [ __ ]
all right now what happens there I don't
understand how the [ __ ] whatever I
just it's it's interesting whatever I'll
have the link up there if you guys can
uh translate it for me I'd appreciate it
there you go
that was Bill Nye the science not the
Science Guy
I got some of it right you got to be
impressed with the high pressure low
pressure [ __ ] weren't you
well go [ __ ] yourself what are you
impressed by huh your own Bulls
um
so anyways what else do I have to do
here
I mean I mean what else do I have to do
for you people you know what I'm going
to do I'm going to read the last two
advertising this week you know
and if you actually paid to advertise on
here and you don't like my reads my
reads are [ __ ] great because I even
as much as I'm [ __ ] on whatever I'm
saying it keeps people listening all
right and they buy stuff by the way
guess what I'm wearing a pair of I'm
wearing a pair of me undies me undies no
more sweaty balls I'm wearing them they
send them to me back to this [ __ ] and I
watched a really cool documentary um
called Nixon on Nixon
which is basically the tapes from the
White House
that he set up the Nixon tapes and then
also interviews that he had and um
this guy puts Archie Bunker to shame
you know but granted it's also like I
mean
the guy taped himself for like six years
however long he was in office he had one
term and then he won the next one I
think within a year or so he was out
what 668 to 74. basically five six years
so of course all they pick out is when
he's saying anti-semitic [ __ ] when he's
saying you know stuff about
minorities his stuff about women I mean
Jesus Christ this guy like
he sounds like Archie Bunker
but uh it's just a really fascinating
thing I highly recommend it
and um
just how like they say the Press is the
enemy the Press is the enemy and how you
think it's like this evil thing like
they're sitting there going like yes we
must lie to the American people their
view is literally the Press is the enemy
because they're distorting what it is
we're trying to say which is the classic
thing where everybody thinks that
they're doing right and it's the right
thing I'm a [ __ ] and I enjoyed it and I
think you will too
sure we all do let's get to some
questions here this week
oh by the way I was in New York City uh
barely had time to do anything uh I went
and I recorded
we uh we got a a big time actor to do
one of the roles on my show F is for
family
I had a great time doing that and uh I
can't [ __ ] wait for this show to come
out we're doing the last records today
and uh I'm not allowed to say I guess
some of the people that we got on this
thing and we signed another person to do
it
and yeah
um we're gonna have to record today yeah
um so anyways the stock market uh Billy
Market belt
are you involved are you involved the oh
are you involved in the buying and
trading of stocks or mutual funds do you
have a business manager diversifying
your [ __ ]
come to San Diego and go [ __ ] yourself
that is an unbelievably personal [ __ ]
question
but I'll answer it
um this is what I think about the stock
market I think it's a
I I just I think it's it's
um it's like Vegas
it's just a crap table
and I think insider trading happens all
the time and I think those people who go
in and they drive the market up and then
they pull their money out and it falls
down and then they fight they buy it low
and they do it all the [ __ ] time and
the same people that do that put the
money behind these campaigns
for the people who become president and
only make five hundred thousand dollars
a [ __ ] year and that's why people
look the other way and then once every
[ __ ] 20 years they throw a celebrity
chef in in jail to make it seem like
they're doing something
them
um
am I in the stock market uh sort of but
not really I'm super conservative and uh
I just look at my retirement account
that I just wanted to still be there
I'm not worried about it gaining
interest I'm just more worried about the
sum of the money
um
but I don't look at my retirement fund
like it's even going to be there the way
these banks are [ __ ]
running wild is Hulk Hogan says and
nobody is trying to stop these guys and
I've lately been [ __ ] bitching about
why we're still having [ __ ] Wards
over in the Middle East
um and fighting [ __ ] terrorist groups
of 30 [ __ ] people who don't even have
a [ __ ] airplane
you know what I mean
like they're gonna come over here and do
something to us
and like what destroy this [ __ ]
company of course they could come over
here and they could [ __ ] blow
something up yeah all right we're gonna
survive that
we need to spend billions of [ __ ]
dollars over there
going after 30 000 [ __ ] jerk-offs
you know meanwhile you got insurance
companies and bankers raping everybody
over here and then you got other people
poisoning the food supply
you know
what do they got that that
they're so [ __ ] powerful like you're
not even allowed to say what's in the
food
you got this dumb [ __ ] you're watching
the World Series and they have stand up
for cancer and nobody's talking about
the [ __ ] food supply and then if you
criticize this I'm standing up for
cancer like you don't give a [ __ ] about
and they just start they always just
start yelling at people
and they never yell at the [ __ ] five
[ __ ] guys
that they could actually change the [ __ ]
it drives me up the [ __ ] wall
it's like that that whole [ __ ] no
more campaign classic NFL
classic NFL like they're reprimanding
you like you were the one who didn't
show that whole [ __ ] tape
at the very least they're trying to say
we're all guilty it's like no you're
guilty you [ __ ]
so whatever
so that's what I say I say bring the
boys and girls home and uh you know we
start out we invade the [ __ ] people
that are putting all this crazy [ __ ] in
the food supply I'd start with that I'd
knock on some bankers house
you know
you're like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you know
that's would make everybody's life way
better
I would think
rather than going after [ __ ] 5 000
people working out on a jungle gym
Bill you're kind of oversimplifying
things well that's what I do
if you don't like it listen to another
[ __ ] podcast you want to listen to
some of you read see it go listen to Joe
Rogan
there's an informed human being all
right
you listen to The Joe Rogan Experience
to learn things you listen to my podcast
to feel better about yourself to feel
smarter
you know
does that make you feel good huh that
you're smarter than me well [ __ ] you all
right
okay here we go
farmer Bill hey Bill let's say the
apocalypse goes down uh I would take a
steak knife and stick it in my neck
and I would hum my Jingle Bells and
that's how I would end it he goes uh
anyways he goes she
you get to that farm and you realize you
only have three crops
oh you you get to that farm what farm
did I say I was gonna have a farm no
Jesus I didn't know you already lost me
two sentences in but I'll keep reading
what do you grow you might be living off
these three fruits are vegetables for a
while so you got to be smart
also you need to think about how you
might combine them to change it up a bit
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself first of all
I don't have to do any of that
I have to answer this [ __ ] question I
resent the fact that you're telling me
that I have to do this when you can't
even [ __ ]
you're writing sentences as bad as I
speak
um but I'll answer it I'll answer it
um
so I when I get to that farm
and I and if I could have three crops
what would I grow
let's see here
I'd have two vegetables and a fruit
right
would that work out
I guess I'd have some sort of lettuce
well first of all the fruit I like
bananas it's very hard to get sick of
bananas I could eat a banana every day
boom banana potassium
no matter what I'm gonna end up getting
some sort of scurvy right
maybe I need an orange
trying to think of all this [ __ ] what
would happen when you get scurvy you
know what I I can't answer it I'd have
to read up on nutrition
I didn't know that there was going to be
a test this week everybody
if I was just going by taste I would
have a banana
uh some sort of lettuce
and then what's another vegetable that I
like
I don't know apples
yeah my so my vegetables would be uh
lettuce and apples
and then the fruit would be a banana
so there you go
now I want to ask everybody who just
listened there like how excited did you
get
that you thought that I actually thought
that an apple was a vegetable
you know and it made you feel better
about you and your [ __ ] stupid life
that for for one second you were right
and somebody else was wrong what does
that say about you as a person
if you didn't actually just hear me say
that and then actually feel sad like oh
no
oh no he's gonna make a fool of himself
if it actually made you [ __ ] happy
you know
do you think that I'm going to wish you
a Happy Thanksgiving I hope you fall
face first into the gravy what do you
think about that right in front of your
mom and when you pick up your [ __ ]
half burned up face and you're pulling
that lot off your face I would just love
for you to see the disappointment in her
eyes that's what I want for you
on this wonderful week for giving thanks
um Jesus Christ how [ __ ] heavy-handed
are they going to be
you know
the NFL right this week when they do
their [ __ ] Thanksgiving games
you know they're going to have like a
camouflage [ __ ] turkey for the troops
and then you know there's going to be
something about some disease
this is what they're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna say no more hitting women
with the camouflage turkey leg
with a cancered riddle
camouflage turkey
while supporting the troops that's what
they're going to say I think they're
going to combine all of that and at some
point I imagine everybody's going to
stand up for some for something
they're going to stand up for a disease
I stand up for cancer sounds like you
support cancer doesn't it stand up for
cancer stand up for it
how about shouldn't we stand up against
cancer
am I slowly losing my mind and like I
don't understand the English language
all of a sudden am I getting some sort
of uh
I don't know
I don't know what the [ __ ] I can't even
I don't know what the [ __ ] to tell you I
just
I just wish they would just play the
games
just show the get I don't need you to
try to make me be a better person
all right I'm a piece of [ __ ]
and I'm trying okay I don't need to be
[ __ ] like
I don't need you to be my [ __ ] parent
all right fireplace uh Billy Claus
uh I'm thinking of uh oh what about
avocados
Gotta Love an avocado
hey I'm back uh I'm back on my diet here
this is how I lose weight I juice
morning and lunch and then I try to eat
[ __ ] as veggie as I can for the rest
of the [ __ ] day and then you just
skip the rope you skip the rope and it
melts off you that's it then you're done
then you're in Billy Bob Thornton shape
all right fireplace Billy Claus I'm
thinking fixing I'm thinking fixing up
my basement you're thinking of fixing up
your basement the previous owner had a
fireplace plastered over it's either a
traditional fireplace or a wood stove
do you have any I don't know I'm
supposed to assume and understand that
literally the way you wrote that I mean
it sounded like behind the wall was
either a traditional fireplace or a wood
stove I'm like what the who the [ __ ]
would have a wood stove and a wall
um
do you have any female maybe there is is
there when I think of a wood stove it's
it's sitting in the middle of a room
yeah [ __ ] now I gotta go I got a Google
image it
I got a Google image
why babe
when I'm going down the road you guys
just enjoy this music while I look this
up uh don't do [ __ ] something wonder
why babe
when I'm going down the road
I used to do something something else
would stop I can't sing and type at the
same time
it made me
yeah wood stove yeah it sits out in the
[ __ ] there it is I'm doing what Paul
verzie does dude I Googled wooden stoves
and none of them were in a wall yeah
none of them are in a wall okay
I mean someday I gave her my heart but
she wanted my soul
Don't Think Twice It's all right all
right fireplace hey Billy Claus I'm
thinking of fixing up my basement the
previous owner had a fire what fireplace
plastered over so it's either the
traditional fireplace or wood stove
that's how you should have written do
you have any feelings either way pros
and cons on them on the matter
um
oh I'd go into the wall dude if you got
a fireplace man they don't allow him
anymore
you know
I don't know where the [ __ ] you live
where you could actually have a wood
stove
I didn't think that they allowed that
anymore
you could just have some [ __ ] coming out
of the chimney
um but you know if you actually already
have a fireplace
if that system is already there
yeah but then the [ __ ] chimney is
going to be [ __ ] up
and then you have to fix that I would
you know I would go the expensive route
that's what I do
I would die I would take it I would have
the exposed brick this is the original
brick from the early 1920s back when
Babe Ruth was playing in a softball
league
dude they were doing the Charleston when
the guy was hitting home runs I mean
Jesus give me a [ __ ] break Batman
like that was a hit song
[ __ ] women walking around wearing
swimming caps
that's when guys that had one piece
bathing suits and went down to your
[ __ ] knees and they had just stripes
across it
they didn't have a [ __ ] lifeguard you
just went into the ocean and you drowned
and like that that was it nobody got
sued
I don't [ __ ] know anyways uh yeah I
would I would
I would unearth the [ __ ] fireplace
that's what I would do
um anyways hey we're still trying to
raise money for the all things comedy uh
Studio we're getting closer by the day
we really appreciate everybody uh your
donations stand up for the new all
things comedy professional studio
we would greatly appreciate it uh I'm
excited all things comedies uh Ari
Shaffer
is taping a new stand-up special this
very week
uh Joe Rogan
friend of the Monday Morning podcast uh
he has a new stand-up special
that just debuted on Comedy Central
please look for that the great Joe Rogan
and
um rumor has it that I might be out at
the ice house with him this Wednesday
night right before Thanksgiving
all right and with that we're going to
end with a little holiday song okay have
yourself a Happy Thanksgiving eat some
turkey for me mashed potatoes and some
[ __ ] yams for you
and don't get into a fight no matter how
much your brother's a dick hello people
it's once again that time of year when
douchebags on TV tell you to stop and
think about everything that you have
you know
millionaires on television
sitting there getting blown right before
the take that they did
to tell you to sit back and feel
thankful for everything that you have
this is the thing you know what would be
a great goal is if you're going home for
Thanksgiving okay especially if you're
in your college Years
and you're still I [ __ ] hate my
parents if you could just somehow go
there
and not yell at anybody not get drawn
into a fight okay when one of your
siblings who makes those passive
aggressive comments because they're
competing
for the attention of your parents
because subconsciously they realize that
despite what your mother says you are
her favorite
you know you're just gonna I I never had
kids but you I it's impossible you got I
mean
you know I love the Bruins I have my
favorite player
you know what I mean
speaking of which Jesus Christ we got to
get healthy good Lord [ __ ] lost to
the Canadians again
I actually sat down and I enjoyed the
Rangers beating the [ __ ] out of the
Canadians something that we haven't been
able to do this year but you know you're
gonna have those letdown Gates but the
Canadians look good God damn it those
bastards look good
um anyways
so yeah so why don't you do that
okay
do that sit down and have some [ __ ]
food I would love to have Thanksgiving
this year but I got dust in my [ __ ]
um
hear that hear the knocking downstairs
people knocking but you can't come in
all right that's the podcast for this
week uh seriously have yourself
a uh Happy Thanksgiving thank you uh you
know what I'm thankful for that people
listen to this podcast
um oh and you know what I announced I'm
so freaking excited about this
um I and um
oh Jesus the hammer is coming now I uh
we we announced the uh my Australian
tour
on the internet and uh we got to get the
dates up on my website but I'm going to
be going
to basically all the major cities in
Australia except for the one that begins
with an a that I got a bunch of [ __ ]
from
where people were giving me [ __ ] you
know
for not going over there I'm just taking
a 20-hour [ __ ] flight to Perth can
you also [ __ ] come here why don't you
guys get on a choo choo train do you
guys even have trains in Australia
we able to build them or did the [ __ ]
everybody went to build them get bit by
a [ __ ] some ridiculously Inland
something or other
it has enough Venom to kill 200
elephants because there's no [ __ ]
food supply out of there so when they
bite you they got to make a sure it
counts
um yeah why don't you do me a solid just
you know I'll take a 20-hour flight you
can jump on a [ __ ] train for 45
minutes
drink some little creatures beer
oh man I can't wait to drink that [ __ ]
when I'm over there oh let me tell you
Billy's going to get fat when he's over
there um and then I'm gonna go to New
Zealand
and I'm going to do two dates over there
and uh Rumor Has It
that um I might be adding some Asia some
Asia dates
onto this tour
and uh to give you a hint to give you an
a hint
um
let's see how can I let me see if I know
enough about any of these
countries to give you a hint all right
I'm going to give you a hint one of
these
I'm going to be going to the land
anybody who's English speaking in the
crowd will be either an expatriate or a
telemarketer
all right come on people where are the
telemarketers from
when you call up hello my name is Frank
right where are they from
um I'm gonna do a stand-up show in a
country where I could maybe possibly get
caned afterwards
huh equivalent butt cheeks over there
um I'm gonna do stand up possibly in a
city where right off the coast there
might be some
right in the water right in the bay
there might be some old
army helicopters under the water
and then I'm also going to do a show in
a country where uh
oh Jesus Christ how do I [ __ ] do this
one I'm out of
definitely a bunch of expatriates it's
English speaking
in a country that Nixon
actually broke the science science broke
the Silence with one of his big moves
that he did during his presidency was he
actually went and had a big meeting with
these guys
all right
there you go it's going to be an insane
tour
and uh I'll probably lose money on most
of the nights especially with those last
ones I mean and you know where the [ __ ]
I'm going to be performing but I'm going
God damn it
why the [ __ ] wouldn't you that's it and
uh anyways everybody have a Happy
Thanksgiving uh you know come on tell
your family you love them don't get
drawn into the fights
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
where we will preview week number 12 of
course sponsored by the best sponsors
the best lines makers out there it is
the BET MGM guys bet MGM is the best
lines out there the best available lines
always live in how do you get bet MGM
you go you download the app you use
bonus code Burr
b-u-r-r you put a minimum of ten dollars
in and you can get up to a thousand
dollars uh matched in free bets all you
got to do is put the bonus code bird put
as little as ten bucks they will match
your bet uh up to a thousand bucks uh
even if you lose your bet so there you
go there you have it
um
we uh we gained some on you we gained
some on the book this week Bill gains
half of a game I finally did the [ __ ]
unimaginable uh Wednesday yeah you sure
I'm not one I was wasn't one two and one
I mean I don't think I was two one and
one
Andrew said I was 2-1-1 I thought it was
one two and one uh you pushed with the
Falcons and the Bears
you won with the bills
no I didn't I thought the bills was
eight and a half
it was seven and a half you won oh okay
um and uh you won okay then I got I got
it because I thought I lost the bills I
thought that was eight and a half
nice oh you listened back well listen
back hey the proof is proof is in the
recording oh I was gonna [ __ ] sit
there and be like Jesus Christ because I
I thought I lost another one because of
the [ __ ] prevent defense
no they just stopped playing Paul they
play defense the whole game they just
stopped [ __ ] playing and then hey
here's a touchdown
no consideration
so that's great don't let him get behind
you what about me getting behind the
book you think they care what about my
Prime Mick I wish you had a prime
um you know not every team does that
though thank God thank God they don't do
that who doesn't do it
the Giants don't do it I didn't see the
Chiefs doing it this year the Chiefs I
think learned after last before
what's that
dude they do it when they're up 14
points
and they gotta win by eight and a half
15. they [ __ ] do it
dude it really is sucks as a better it
really does suck as a better to know
to know that all right yeah I'm up 21 we
covered and then all of a sudden
starters come out everybody lays back
it's so [ __ ] stupid it's like you
picked the right team and then they make
you pick the wrong one
well here's the best part bill you
gained half a game I finally got out of
the [ __ ] Gutter and we are Andrew
what are the records now
no if I'm two one and one I gained uh
one and a half games yeah bill bill you
are at a hairline split you're a 20 20
and four
all right so that's two games above and
and uh Paul you are 21 22 and one
so all right we're right there we're
right there so we're right there man
we're right there we're gonna have came
back Paul
strong last few weeks strong last week
strong last three weeks but hey it means
nothing it means nothing if you give it
back let's get into this week's let's
guys sound like a coach right sound like
a coach don't get excited okay you gotta
go out there and do it again all right
so here we go we go into the picks this
is week number 12.
um so I had the first pick this year
which is the odd numbers so Bill you
have first pick this week
yeah I don't understand why the Colts to
ten point dogs in a division rivalry
against the Cowboys is there something I
don't know is your quarterback hurt
no the Cowboys that's not the right game
Cowboys are playing the Giants on
Thanksgiving that's what I'm saying
the Giants I remember I said the wrong
thing I said the Colts you said the
Colts all right why are the Giants
getting 10 points I'm gonna tell you why
dude and I hate to admit this as a giant
fan but we lost
we lost one of the best cornerbacks and
basically a pro bowl cornerback this
year Dory Jackson is out you want to
know why because they decided to let him
be a punt returner
every time a star is a punt returner
guess what he [ __ ] gets hurt let that
be a special teams guy let it be a
special teams or like a third or fourth
[ __ ] wide receiver to do it okay they
kicked the ball back so far back now
anyway you're not getting it's not worth
the risk is not worth the reward okay
how far does a guy get they shouldn't
even kick off and give a [ __ ] Paul
I give a [ __ ] boys had a big game they
had a big game last [ __ ] week they
ran all over the Vikings it's a division
rivalry you lost the cornerback I'm
getting 10 [ __ ] points with the
Giants historically I don't give a [ __ ]
they're a great defensive team I'm
taking the Giants on the road against
the Cowboys getting 10 points
all right I like I mean look I hope hey
I want that to be a win like you like
you read about
um you want to straight up win
yeah all right so
I'm gonna go with my first pick for week
number 12.
I'm gonna go where is it here ah man
this is a tough one dude
you you are starting on Thanksgiving
with 10 points which is good hold on
uh I'm fro oh here we go
NFL all right
dude do I go Buffalo Bills are Buffalo
Bills
are given nine and a half points in
Detroit Detroit just won three games in
a row
they are at home this is kind of their
big one
I'm staying away
um staying away from it I take the Lions
because the [ __ ] bills are going to
be up by 14 15 and then they're just
gonna [ __ ] give them a touchdown if I
was going to go either way
if it's north of eight eight and a half
take the dog
you get a Vikings Cowboys game but
generally speaking the team the
favorites gonna cover it and in the end
they just [ __ ] give it it's dude it's
ridiculous they don't even take away the
sidelines I actually can't argue that
because I've seen that happen all but
once this year so numbers would say that
that's right and nine is a lot
especially on a Thanksgiving game but
I'm gonna take it's coming three free
timeouts in a 20-yard [ __ ] cushion
and four shots at the [ __ ] End Zone
then we're gonna start playing d
I'm gonna take the Minnesota Vikings
beating the Patriots by three it's minus
two and a half I think Minnesota got so
humiliated last week 40-3 and uh they're
playing you know I don't like that the
Patriots couldn't score more than
[ __ ] three points on the Jets for
three hours
um I normally wouldn't do that but I'm
gonna take the Vikings to have a bounce
back game and uh she scored seven points
at two hours and 59 minutes just to let
you know so we did score seven
um I think that the defense is gonna
Rush Mac Jones and turn you know make
him make some mistakes I'm gonna take
them to win by a field goal on
Thanksgiving night
all right I like the uh Atlanta Falcons
getting four and a half first the
Commanders
it's a great [ __ ] pick I was thinking
dude the Falcons just come back you look
at at 135 they're down 28 and then all
of a sudden at 350. it's I believe in
Marcus Mariota and I also think uh
you know I I just [ __ ] you know
I just
I'm a little jaded here Paul just just
stay away from me this week
I'm gonna ruin the party
oh you oh okay something happened I'm
not I'm just [ __ ]
I mean I get given up the middle of the
field but just giving them the sidelines
and everybody dude back in the day you
had to be Joe Montana yeah they even
practice the two-minute offense anymore
what is the two-minute offense the
[ __ ] defense gets off the field until
today stay away from me this week is one
of the it's like you get like scratched
by a zombie and you don't know if you're
gonna turn so you just tell the people
you love
all goddamn year and I've had it
um trying to kick that football all year
Paul I ain't doing it anymore
um
oh man
I'm gonna take I'm gonna ride it again
man I I'm gonna ride it again I'm gonna
take the Indianapolis Colts you
[ __ ] on on my goddamn paper you
son of a [ __ ] you a [ __ ] Raiders and
Packers all year I rode the [ __ ]
Colts in Tennessee now here you are some
Packers over my shoulder I'll tell you
what finally jumping off that Packers
train is why I'm [ __ ] trying to make
a comeback dude it's over and I can't
believe I'm saying it I'm gonna take the
the Colts to beat the Steelers dude the
Steelers quarterback just isn't the guy
it's just not the commercial you learned
it by watching me
um all right
no you actually took the Colts the first
three weeks of the season and then I
took them three [ __ ] weeks nobody
owns a team I'm just being but I'll tell
you Paul stay away from me this week uh
minus two and a half all right minus two
and a half I got one for you Paul the
[ __ ] Rams are getting 14 and a half
points in the division rivalry game
against the Chiefs I'll take that I'll
watch the Chiefs go up by 21 and then
stop playing defense and give him a
[ __ ] touchdown
got more Pride than that Paul I think
they're [ __ ] good looking coach is
done getting lap dances in the back room
at Applebee's and I think maybe he's
thinking his house is on the [ __ ]
line and I don't think they're gonna
lose by that much
he gets the unlimited ribs
keep the racks coming my goal this week
Paul is I want to start collectively
plus 85 points
um
I'm not gonna get trapped I almost got
trapped by the Raiders again dude I
almost just took the Raiders I almost I
thought I was going to take the Raiders
last week and they're covered against
the [ __ ] hapless Broncos
dude there's some kid on the internet
is doing this [ __ ] hilarious thing
that should have been over by the
beginning of October
it was like at what point
is uh uh [ __ ] oh my God I can never
remember his [ __ ] name
the quarterback uh
I [ __ ] love him he's like one of my
favorite quarterback quarterback for the
Broncos Russell Wilson Oh Russell Wilson
[ __ ] Wilson I mean don't forget about
that name Russell you've been slipping
that guy's name all seasonal and I love
him and I don't blame him for the
Broncos situation whatsoever I'd love it
if the Pats got him
dude Russell Wilson's kid's been doing
this thing on Twitter going at what
point during the season will Russell
Wilson have more touchdown passes than
he has bathrooms in his mansion
and he still has more bathrooms
and he talks about the bathrooms like
they're a team bathrooms getting it done
again this week
it's 14 bathrooms touchdown
I love that it's [ __ ] hilarious oh I
love that
um all right for my third pick
for my third pick I'm actually this is
one that could bite me but I'm gonna
take
the Broncos are given 13 and a half and
I'm gonna take the Broncos and here's
why they're coming off a bye week and I
have seen nothing week in and week out
from the Texans and when I mean nothing
I mean you want to talk about hapless
quarterback throwing up [ __ ] gifts to
the D-backs I think Miami what's the
spread 13 and a half
I'll tell you this they got a [ __ ]
Maniac genius as a head coach running
this new [ __ ] offense that utilizes
Tyreek Hill and that other guy he's seen
that [ __ ] they put Tyreek Hill in
[ __ ] motion and then they stack him
and he starts running past them and they
don't know what to do yeah his name is
Mike McDaniel do you know that he's best
friends with Dan Soder comedian Dan
Soder and the head coach of the Miami
Dolphins have been best friends since
seventh grade
you know what's funny is I look like the
head coach of the bills and Nick crow
looks like the head coach of Miami we
should watch a game together wearing
those colors with headsets what are you
gonna say Andrew
Broncos Panthers it's Broncos Panthers
this weekend the Panthers are getting
two and a half
no but I'm I'm taking the Dolphins
Texans I thought you said Broncos no no
no no no I was talking Broncos
dolphin sex sorry I'm taking it I
thought that you said Broncos I'm taking
I'm taking the Dolphins minus 13 and a
half they're gonna win that game by over
20.
all right Paul I'm having fun this week
I'm having fun I don't give a [ __ ] you
know it's the holidays I like
Thanksgiving unlike you I got all my
relatives
coming over and if you know
it's [ __ ] you know smooth Paul no
lumps in the gravy over there right I'm
gonna take the Saints get nine and a
half versus the 49ers and their [ __ ]
unbelievable defense and all that I
think they're going to be unbelievable
defense so right at the end of the
[ __ ] game I like uh yeah and I want
to talk bad about Italians but I don't
know I just see Jimmy G throwing a
[ __ ] tick I don't know why I see an
end zone pick uh what are they throwing
they left it on the [ __ ] or they're
gonna go for it on fourth down fourth
and goal instead of kick in the field
goal because everybody thinks for some
reason that's leaving [ __ ] three
field goals on the [ __ ] table
doesn't matter if the next time you go
for it you go one of those times you get
a touchdown
they go for it fourth and goals three
times in a row They Come Away with seven
points and they think that's better than
nine
dude I call it Millennial math Paul you
have text messages from me from many
many years ago and why didn't you kick
why didn't you kick it's half a
touchdown it's half a touchdown
I don't understand take the [ __ ]
points it's almost half a touchdown with
the extra point it's [ __ ] stupid take
it man take [ __ ] guys can kick 50
yard yarders now like the 50 yard is
like the new 45 yard or dude nobody's
kicking 50 yards back when when the
[ __ ] field goal kicker was in the
same shape as an NHL goalie that's where
you put your [ __ ] non-athlete back in
the day
dude like [ __ ] European guys over
here they come over here Barefoot and
they couldn't deal with how much steak
and toilet paper there was they didn't
have to stand in a line they didn't know
their head was spinning no one could hit
a 50 yarder back then I watched the game
this week a guy kicks a 60-yarder and
all of a sudden they were like wait a
minute we didn't review oh yeah you told
me about that we didn't review and then
the and then they go all right and they
asked the coach the coach goes let him
kick it again and four minutes later he
banged it even better the second time
260 yarders in a row that's what she
said okay hey uh all right so how many
do I have one more left
all right yeah yeah dude I was talking
to bartnick he goes I think they should
just get rid of the kitchen game all
together
well that I disagree with 100 that's
like all of that dumb [ __ ] where it's
just like they should coach a game to
[ __ ] go for it I mean there's no
strategy there's no nothing
this is my deal Paul if you don't like
defense and you don't like kicking the
like the [ __ ] idiots last year who
thought the cheese first the bills was
one of the greatest football games
they'd ever seen in their life it's like
what the [ __ ] are you what were you
watching that was the most atrocious
defense in a playoff game I've ever
[ __ ] seen ever that was great for a
video game with your buddy
yeah that's great if you don't want to
win a championship and guess what Paul
neither one of them won a [ __ ]
championship last year because their
defense sucked oh dude you left me a two
minute you left me a two-minute audio
message after that game
it's just like you know what Paul I
swear to god dude this defenses does
anybody gonna play defense dude 13
seconds you can't allow that dude was
like watching [ __ ] Rocky three
where every punch you're like dude that
would have knocked somebody out that
would have knocked somebody out was
stupid dude my favorite thing about the
wrong like Nick Cage should have been
one of the quarterbacks dude if you
listen to the sound effects of Rocky 3
when they connect you went Clubber Lang
connects it looks like it would kill
somebody what about the fact that he
growls like a grizzly bear Supernatural
when he was doing them sit-ups
good good villain though good boxing
villain for a movie dude it's a great
[ __ ] movie I'm not coming down on
Rocky 3. okay it's a movie no I'm
watching a [ __ ] NFL game that looks
like a movie that's weird dude as an
Italian Rocky's the closest thing to
Godfather to me like dude it's it's dude
Sly Stallone what he did for me dude
when he beat the Russian and Rocky IV
dude my life changed I'm not even joking
dude I like ran outside and thought I
could do anything like that's why that
guy's not really Russian Paul that was
an actor
I'm never gonna get rid of this cough by
the way I mean did Rocky help stop the
Cold War
I think he did
all right here we go
so women Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan
kept getting more and more missiles
Jefferson
Gorbachev was like you know the the not
quite as hot chick that hangs out with
the influencer that's what he was and he
was trying to buy all the same red
bottom shoes and he couldn't keep up and
that's what happened
what had happened was we he was a
[ __ ] human being as opposed to now we
got a dementia guy and a [ __ ]
sociopath
dude you know what they should have had
built they should have politician
playing cards how [ __ ] dope would
that be like having a having a George
Washington would be like having a Babe
Ruth
be like y'all doing trading cards I got
that grand I got I got that Grant
I got that Grant rookie card when he
didn't have the beard yet
you know historically speaking generals
have made terrible [ __ ] presidents
um has reality show stars and people
with dementia
not good presidents for sure all right
so so far I have what do I have Andrew I
got the Vikings I have the
dolphins and Colts dolphins and Colts
and my fourth and final pick
going into week number 12
um
hey Paul I'm up 34 and a half points
collectively this week
yeah no dude you're
listen nobody could question you I'm
just this is the thing I think the NFL
just wants [ __ ] close games
I'm gonna tell you dude I'm I'm
petrified of this Bengals Titans game
one and a half it's a pick em it's
basically a coin toss I stayed away from
that it's in Tennessee
all right Paul birthday coming over to
[ __ ] coming over to Bill Burst cheat
sheet
Tennessee
I didn't take Tennessee
you're on your way you're on your way
I'm not taking you on your way Paul I
don't own teams I'm just I told you stay
away from me this week
I'm gonna take Tom Brady off of a bye
week I don't like that it's three and a
half
I don't like that it's three and a half
but I like that it's Cleveland and I
think that uh I think the Buccaneers got
their defense a little bit of rest
I think they'd win that game by a
touchdown or six I'm gonna take the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers to beat the hapless
Cleveland Browns minus
I love that pick
I love that
I didn't see that and then once you
broke it down
you know Paul you're looking a little
Russian these days
you know with the shaved head and that
[ __ ] you know that dark beard dude
I'm down I'm down
I'm down 12 years I'm down 12 pounds
well I don't give a [ __ ] about your
weight I want to know what you're doing
against the bookie
you don't care if I'm fat or skinny what
are you doing plus 12 at the beginning
of this season now he's the favorite
he's mine is 12.
dude is there anything better than
losing 12 pounds right before
Thanksgiving uh dude I haven't had a
drink in almost 20 days and I I got to
be honest with you man
I don't think I'm picturing you with the
Thanksgiving with your arms tied behind
your back with your face in the plate
like a pipe and contest
I lost 12 pounds somebody
dude I don't want a drink man I hate the
way I feel after I drink now it's over
man
oh it's the worst dude it's it's two
glasses of wine I feel horrible in the
morning I'm tired I don't want to get
out of bed I've been drinking 20 days oh
it's for young people let them have
their fun we had our fun I'm not gonna
[ __ ] on drinking totally but when you
get to Branch Paul you know when you
when you're as old as the second
semester [ __ ] senator
state senator at that point you got to
hang it up right second term is that
what they call it
um Bill we're getting killed on a Monday
night special buddy I mean we just can't
do it because they went Jim or say on us
they changed the [ __ ] rules and then
that's what happened
the competition committee
yeah we gave him a couple hits they had
a meeting some people you know
the pens flew all right so this is the
over under on uh uh uh I wanna [ __ ] I
want to bet on can you bet on the
Westminster dog show me and my wife do
that with each other every year I think
you can
I don't know if it's two years in a row
and I just haven't I'm [ __ ] I can't
see the dogs anymore man I'm not me
stealing your line what uh what do you
think Bill you know what time it is
oh let the Monday nights special
win some money for you
let the Monday night special we gotta
hit one this week it is the Pittsburgh
Steelers going into the Indianapolis
Colts and the Colts are laying two and a
half and the under overs 39. I like the
Colts I like whoever the Colts
quarterback is to throw a [ __ ]
touchdown what's the Under Armor
oh I brought Ryan back Matt Ryan's back
I thought they punched him for the kid
and then when they got the new coach
they put him in and he had two really
good games that's what I would think
dude the fact that they're blaming Matt
Ryan that the Colts think the fact that
they're blaming Russell Wilson
that the Broncos say Russell Wilson was
the [ __ ] with Seattle Matt Ryan was
[ __ ] great with Atlanta all right but
you know a lot of times the [ __ ] and
then like here then they go on these
teams and what they forgot how to play
quarterback because they got traded the
[ __ ] out of here stink
well here's the thing though the reason
why Russell Wilson they're not playing
for him is because he pulled an Ellen
Bill he pulled in Ellen oh stop with
that [ __ ] real housewife for [ __ ]
Paul I don't give a [ __ ] you won't give
me my cell phone number
really in a million dollars a year
to go out and play football I don't give
a [ __ ]
dude if you saw your if you saw your
teammate doing cartwheels up and down
the aisle of the plane when you're
sleeping for four hours I wouldn't annoy
you
and he's not gonna even know that
happened
what's that [ __ ] sports reporter told
you that who never got picked in gym
class
I think Bronco players were complaining
about is that's where they got it from I
think but what did they tweet about it
what kind of a man rats out his [ __ ]
quarterback he's doing he did a little
Molly after the game he wants to feel
the rug on his feet and His Hands that's
not wrong with that
um all right so then that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna go Maddie I used to
throw one we're gonna go over over 39
and the coach I didn't say over I didn't
say what what's what's it's 39 and who
they playing the Steelers you said over
didn't you
I don't I don't know what I said okay
it's 39 they're playing the Steelers
I think this field has scored a bunch of
points next week and I don't think that
they're gonna do it again
okay
all right we'll go under listen that's a
coin I don't like how easy your swayed
here Paul you're not pushing no you
don't want to know why because the under
Rovers ruined every because ronder over
is a coin toss it's FL it does there's
no skill in it unless it's raining
unless it's weather
so I'll ride with you whichever way you
want to [ __ ] go because it's stupid
all right stop yelling at me
um all right we'll go under
and I love them to win the game minus
two and a half
and I love you
I love you dude are you still sick
oh when you're [ __ ] screaming your
act
and you have a cough for an hour and 20
minutes every [ __ ] weekend and you do
19 podcasts a week it's kind of hard to
get over a cough
that is true I got over the cold the
cough is feeling pretty good but like
you know
I blew up I couldn't do the Monday
Morning podcast this week but now I got
to do it for Thursday one
you know why Paul because there's a
bunch of guys out there in Loveless
marriages having people coming over for
Thanksgiving and that's just sitting
there carving the turkey they're
thinking like what if I just took this
knife and stuck it right in the neck of
my [ __ ] wife's brother-in-law's
brother or whatever right they can't do
it
they ride out another holiday Paul
I'm gonna carve the turkey I'm The
Turkey Carver in this house you know
what gets them through it Paul
what a [ __ ] podcast done by a couple
of Knuckleheads to bet on football
that's right that's all like some some
guys Paul some guys Paul that's all they
got listen I want to say something here
and I want to and you know I've been
very humble as much as I can on this
podcast this year because I was losing
but a lot of tweet a lot of Twitter
people came at me going oh Paul the pics
are real rough this year oh God you guys
are [ __ ] the bet this year I just
want to say listen it's not over yet and
that could happen but you know something
just Tweet now I just want you to Tweet
now oh he was ate back and Bill was four
but guess what we're right there [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's a long season how about
that hey Paul they're quitters
quitters they're quitters they don't
like their life and they want you to
fail so they're saying all of this [ __ ]
yeah
it's what they do that's why I don't
watch [ __ ] ESPN and all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] like why do I need to know that
guy's doing a cartwheel down the [ __ ]
first of all that's impressive
that's not a wide aisle well I was
joking about the cart well he was doing
that like high knee [ __ ] and his like
calisthenic workout like on the plane
while people are sleeping
I'm gonna be honest with you dude I'm
gonna be honest with you this is just me
maybe not you me if a guy tells me I'll
have my people give you my number and
then I'm sitting on the plane with a
mask on trying to sleep and he's [ __ ]
running up and down doing that and I
gotta block for him and [ __ ] risk my
life for that [ __ ] on Sunday for me
[ __ ] that guy
that guy should be taking people out I I
disagree with that buy some shrimp for
the team I disagree with that Paul
100 be a [ __ ] Pro risking your life
you [ __ ] 300 pounds you get to eat
whatever the [ __ ] you want is alignment
you get paid millions of dollars to
protect the guy that's your [ __ ] job
your job is not to be friends with them
okay so guess what Kevin McHale and
Larry Bird weren't friends they didn't
[ __ ] hang out Kevin's like we don't
need to be friends they're [ __ ] pros
and I remember one time the [ __ ]
Celtics kicked the [ __ ] out of this team
in the first game of the playoffs and
one of the guys in the other team goes
yeah they better be ready they better be
ready for game two
and [ __ ] Kevin McHale goes you should
be ready every night it's the NBA
so you're gonna sit there and pout and
not block his good because you can't get
the [ __ ] quarterback's phone number
I don't think you go out on the field
with a dress on I don't think the real
laughing [ __ ] no I don't think they're
not blocking for him I just think they
don't like them
but I think they're still you know so
what
yeah I'm just saying but you're
suggesting because they don't like them
because he didn't give them their phone
number
right they couldn't go take a dump in
one of his 14 [ __ ] bathrooms that now
they're not gonna block as hard I just
think a team needs to to have chemistry
and love
you need the owner you need the GM you
need the coach and you need the players
they got the player they got the
quarterback that's one of the best
quarterbacks in the league and all of a
sudden he goes from Seattle to this
[ __ ] he goes from Seattle with Pete
Carroll yeah to this [ __ ] jerk off
it's not a jerk off but a franchise
that's in a jerk-off moment in their
history and now he's taking all the heat
it's stupid he's not the problem
no I I if you're a lineman and he won't
give you his [ __ ] number get over it
you're 300 pounds you can go to a titty
bar and get blown in the VIP room and
it's not enough for you
it's a good point it is a good point
it's a good point
um the rest of your life you're gonna
sit there with your aches and pains
thinking you know I could have tried a
little harder
you had me at you could eat anything you
want
[Laughter]
spin uh let's hope we keep this thing
going oh Bill if we come back next week
don't talk to me about hope
hope gonna pay your rent
um well Happy Thanksgiving guys uh oh by
the way everybody if you have just
recently joined us and and I want to say
this again if
you don't like our underovers on the
Monday night special you can roll with
our pick for
um
you know you can roll that pick for
who's gonna win the game you could take
the Colts you could do all that stuff
um and we thank you guys for jumping on
that we want to win you some money we
will win you some money
um and we're gonna we're about to be
close to the book there so just all you
got to do if you want to ride with us in
bet go to bedmgm download the app use
bonus code bird very simple put as
little as 10 bucks in and they'll match
your bets up to a thousand dollars in
free bets even if you lose guys so there
you go collectively between you you're
on my record we're over 500. picking
eight games a week against the spread I
think we're doing all right
I gotta say if we can be close to where
we are now after this year that's 36
weeks guys that's 36 weeks against the
spread I told you I went on good morning
Football on the NFL Network and they go
Paul we want you to pick a game for the
week it'll be fun and in between the
commercial I go hey dude is this against
the spread and they all burst it out
left and going no
so there you have it everybody those are
our picks going into week number 12. you
got my four picks you got bills four
picks you got the Monday night special
you know to download the app use bonus
code bird put your money in and they
will match up to a thousand as little as
10 bucks we wanna wish you from us to
you from our humble little show uh
anything better NFL preview we want to
wish you and yours a very Happy
Thanksgiving enjoy the food enjoy the
family have yourself hey Happy
Thanksgiving
I hope you hit all your bets by the way
Thanksgiving real quick before we get
out of here not one game with the Lions
not two games with the with the Cowboys
they're going three games you get the
Patriots and Vikings let's be honest
guys it's a fun fun Thanksgiving so be
safe enjoy everybody and we will see you
next week I don't know why I did this I
love that I want that to be your new
thing and we will see you next week
I love that
Happy Thanksgiving everybody and
remember guys Tibet you got to be 21
years of age or older to wager in
Arizona Colorado DC Iowa Indiana Kansas
Michigan Mississippi New Jersey New York
Nevada Pennsylvania Tennessee
uh Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming
only new customer offer paid in free
bets visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4704 Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]